Welcome to Akihabara.
Say the line, boss.
Oh, come on.
I was just a few minutes late.
I was just a little bit late.
Keep joining, huh?
Let's hop right in right.
Oh, I thought they used to do that thing where they'd like
make you go.
I thought they did the glasses.
Yoko?
Choo!
Thank you!
Hi.
Hi Mervi.
Why is this so suspicious?
Tadaiima!
Yeah!
Oh, that's Google Earth.
Oh, we're in Google Maps.
Oh, Taco Glass is where?
Okay, hold on.
Gosh.
Is that better?
They're not otaku glasses though.
They're just regular glasses.
Missing the halo.
T-Tuber-Y!
I- sorry!
I forgot I had to make my tea.
yummy hello everybody i was gonna prepare like a whole thing
for this and then i got busy so sorry i was like ready to
have like a skit and everything in my brain not ready on
paper ready in my brain but um you know actually it's been
several well years since I since I streamed but a long time
ago I did an Akiba tour I think it was for New Year's
actually so improv time okay hold on oh wait I'm missing a
prop oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
Wait, don't, don't look.
Stop looking.
Um, hey,
where's school?
Oh wait, hold on.
I'm all the way back there.
Oh no!
I'm late for school!
Sorry for running into you!
earthquake um oh you need to go to school too do you go to
love live academy just like me oh it's your first day of
class let me show you this shirt was one thousand dollars i
don't have coffee what are you that's the entire loaf i'm a
growing girl what do you want from me
special food that you had a craving for?
I don't want to talk about it because I couldn't even get
it.
Okay?
I'm really depressed about it, actually.
So can we move on?
Where are you growing?
Don't, isn't it?
It's so rude to ask a lady her size.
Please.
You're going to be...
Not VTuber Academy.
To the Love Live Academy too!
Oh my god.
It's insane.
My bread has more physics than I do.
Oh my god, it's the most jiggly bread in the world.
Oh!
Why is it so jiggly?
Okay, I don't know if I can share it.
Okay.
Let's get going!
We're gonna be late for class!
Do you know where?
They went to...
Oh wait.
When they went to school in Love Live, it was...
Oh, wait.
It was the rival school.
Oh, shoot.
Um...
It wasn't the Love Live girls.
Uh-oh, I got it wrong.
Uh-oh.
Um...
Yeah, A-Rise went here.
Just...
Oh wait, no, no, turn around, turn around.
Google!
This way!
Oh, oh my gosh.
They're just like me!
There's ghost people.
Great bit, thanks, Mint.
A real knee slapper.
I knew you would like it.
Goch, goch, goch!
Chah, chah, chah, chah, chah, chah, chah, chah, chah.
Run, run, wait.
I'm trapped inside the...
I'm trapped inside the station!
This...
How do I get out of the station?
It's already night time even.
Who puts salt around the exit?
I wonder what time they took this at.
Oh.
They all think I'm really suspicious, guys.
Oh, no.
They're like, Hey, what's this ghost doing over here?
Why are we in Japan, but we got a Brooklyn accident?
Hey, what's that ghost doing over there with that bread of
ours, that jiggly bread?
Oh, don't mind me, officer.
Don't mind me.
Let's just turn around for them.
Okay, let's go back in.
Oh, no, we can't go back.
Remilia.
Wait a second.
What is going on?
What is going on here?
Um.
actually it says that this was from october 2018 and i'm
almost positive i was here because i got i have goods from
this collab and i went to atore during this collab so um
this one of these is probably me i
was in disguise anyways guys you know what little scuffed.
Oh, it's dates.
Oh, Flan!
Collaboration event.
Let's just start from here.
Welcome to Akihabara!
Welcome, welcome.
Oh my gosh, thank you for the birthday gift and kiss
cubbies.
Thank you!
Yippee!
So Akiba actually, Akiba Station at least, has two exits.
This is the electric town gate, as it says here.
And over there, there's another one all the way down that
end.
If we want to get to like Yodobashi more easily.
So Toho Stream when?
Mmm, mmm, when I wonder.
It's a good idea.
Oh no.
I tried turning off, sorry, wait.
Let me see if I can fix something real quick.
So sorry guys.
I tried turning off the notifs for like the members when
they become members through gifted.
Since it kind of clogs up the notifications a little bit.
But I don't, maybe it didn't work.
Yeah, I turned it off, but it didn't work.
I'll try it later.
Again.
That is basically Danmaku and you're pretty good at handling
that.
So, where's the chubby girl's maid cafe I?
Maximum.
I'll get there.
Holy crap, ghosts.
Yeah, these are the ghosts of Akiba Station.
These are the ghosts of Akihabara Station.
Cool.
Whoa!
Spooky!
And that, that's, um, that's the, that's, he's, see the
ghost.
This is where you pay respect.
So yeah, once you leave Electric Town Gate, um, here's where
you can buy your tickets or charge your suika or pasimo.
You come here.
Scary!
This is Atre right here.
Look, they're all worshiping Remilia.
Oh, Remilia Sama, kawaii!
Remilia Sama, kawaii!
I'm so glad that this is uh that this is like this um they
do they do like anime collabs here about like every two or
three weeks I think so um it's always rotating to different
stuff look at them oh he's bowing he's praying they're in
line to pray to Remilia Sama But Flan is best to who?
How dare you!
Remilia Sama is justice!
It was Bochi the Rock when I was there last.
Oh, I was there for Bochi too.
So this is obviously Halloween time because yeah.
Can I get out of here?
Can I escape?
So, if you go out, if you're facing the gates, and you go
this way, out the left side, Can I change it so it's not
nighttime?
Oh my gosh!
Wait, this is so old!
They haven't even finished the hotel here yet.
That's crazy.
That's so crazy.
Wait, can I change the year?
How can I change the year?
Um...
Emilia, Samma, charisma is amazing.
Yes!
Yeah, and it still says Sega.
Eh.
How do I change the date?
Hold on.
Let me maybe try going back to the map.
And then we're going to zoom in here.
Maybe it'll give us a different date if I come in.
Like right here.
Ta-da!
Aha!
July 2022!
2022.
Welcome to Akihabara Station.
There we go, there we go, there we go.
If you ever see these people, they often do blood drives in
Akihabara.
I've never done it before because I'm terrified of needles.
But if you can donate the blood, I recommend.
And now the hotel that I talked about is completed.
There's a new days, Konbini right here.
I've actually I've never stayed at this hotel before either
but um yeah you got the gigo here which is your um which is
your arcade used to be Sega as you saw
um yeah I don't know how much to say about that it's kind of
sad let's see if we go down here in here you have a made
dreaming um this is the heaven's gate location which if
you're going to I recommend this one the most because it's
the biggest and I think they have the best live stage and
stuff like that So love live love live Collaboration cafe
with me Um,
one two three four five six seven eight nine two ten Shit
Bro thinks she goes here.
But I thought there were only nine girls.
Huh?
Miku is...
What?
I never knew that they had a collab like that.
That's so awesome.
Miku jump scare.
Yeah, right?
Oh.
There's some tourist, like, t-shirt places here.
This is M's.
is just a giant sexy store you know what I mean it's just a
giant everything is sexy in here it's a sexy sexy store I
like the I like the standies they have out here sometimes
they have a VTuber advertising stuff on the television as
well what does that mean?
Let's go in?
Can we?
No.
What's this, though?
I don't know what that is.
I don't know what that's advertising.
Dangerous building.
Y'all bad, isn't it?
Yeah.
It's a bit of...
Let's see.
There's a...
If you're wanting a hotel that is, um, sorry, my, I feel
like my tour is going to be all over the place.
If you guys have any specific questions, let me know.
But, uh, if you're looking for a hotel, a good hotel in the
Akiba area, there's this Washington hotel.
I've stayed here before.
I recommend it.
It's very close, of course, to the station and obviously to
everything as well.
Um, so if you need a good hotel, I recommend.
What's a good hotel?
I'm glad you asked.
If you're looking for a good hotel, I recommend...
Oh god, we have to get past...
We can't go past the patchy slot...
The pachinko machine.
Pachinko parlor.
Wait, we're stuck!
Oh, here we go.
We're stuck.
We can't go past the pachinko.
Our body is getting sucked into the pachinko.
Whoa!
Where's the McDonald's?
I can show you!
Wait, how do I get back?
Oh my gosh.
What is wrong with Google Maps anymore?
Why am I stuck in certain places?
Did he lose the footage?
What happened?
Well, I was gonna show you over there, but I guess we can't.
Uh-oh, I'm stuck again.
Oh!
Maybe let me try with my mouse instead.
Ah!
I mean, not my mouse, I meant my keyboard.
There it is.
And there's also a Denny's right here.
So it's kind of convenient to, like, have the hotel and then
the Denny's.
Mr. Donut Doko?
I'm getting there.
You guys are so impatient.
Oh, my gosh.
But you guys are just excited.
I get it.
Me too.
This part of the Akiba station, there's, like, a Starbucks.
And there's a Mujie.
and there's a GU.
So if you want some more normy kind of stuff, it's over
here.
But down this way...
Meow.
Wow.
The container is still here.
But it's not anymore, unfortunately.
This used to be a store where they would have collab stuff
with different games and anime and stuff like that.
But unfortunately, it's not anymore.
We'll also go down here.
This will... I'll lead you out back home.
Don't worry.
Meow.
Whoa.
So here's Yodobashi.
Which is like your big Yodobashi camera is your big
electronic store.
There's so many floors.
And then up top there's also like lots of restaurants.
There's Tower Records.
There's a Daiso in there.
If you're looking for like...
What's it called?
Um, Yotobashi is huge.
Yeah, it's so, so big.
This was what Akihabara was originally known for before
anime.
Yeah, exactly.
Known for their electronics stuff.
Well, yes, but more so like the smaller electronic stores,
right?
But also in here are a lot of great, um, can we go in there?
No.
Um, in here there's a lot of good little stores.
store there's jack and the donuts which i suggest you don't
but um there's takoyaki there's uh um there's several places
um and then right here's a cat cafe which i've never been to
before though so um yeah um now if we turn around this is
the other side this is that other exit i talked about
earlier so what in the donuts I think you heard me.
What if Akiba had...
Oh, sorry, I was reading the wrong one.
I was wondering, last time you went, do you still hear the
May Dreaming song play basically everywhere?
Only in one place do I hear the May Dreaming song play.
Only in one place, and I can show you where they still play
it.
Top left corner, see there's a more dates button to switch
quickly.
Oh, it wasn't there before though.
Oh, did I miss it just before?
Also, I can't believe I'm backseeing in Google Maps.
Let's go.
What if Akiba had a waffle house?
That would make it perfect, to be honest.
If you were asking about the McDonald's, here's one of them.
Here's one McDonald's that Akiba has to offer you, but
there's actually another one.
What if Akiba got a Wendy's?
Okay, that I would be very excited about.
I actually like first kitchen very much
but yeah you can go in here and get some snacks there's also
um if you need to take the hibia line um so this is the JR
so you're gonna have like the Yamanote line and um Chioda
line and um all those what's what's the yellow one oh my god
I can't remember the names anymore.
I like Jack in the Donut.
Oh,
yes, you know.
Chuo, thank you.
The Chuo, so blind.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
So yeah.
If you come to Akiba and you are taking the Hibiya line, you
will come out over here, actually.
So if you're just like, wait, this doesn't look like the
Akihabara I saw in Mint stream.
Actually, I want I wonder if we can get over there.
I wonder if we can, if we can zoom.
Sorry if the zoom is a little, I'm trying not to go too fast
to give you, give you a whiplash, you know?
Here.
This is where you'll come out the Metro.
So, if you just go through this little way, and then, walk,
walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, you'll reach
Akiba over here.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
You're running over, everyone.
I know.
But yeah, we're just gonna focus on, like, the main, maybe,
like, well, not entirely Chuo-Dori.
We'll go to a different, a couple other places, too.
So, you walk, walk, walk.
What if you come down this way?
I wonder, can we go in here?
Can we go in here?
Um, I don't think we can.
can so if you accidentally don't go out the electric exit
gate payment I know you're probably not gonna see this but
I'm such a big fan oh my gosh thank you thank you yes
sometimes you can choose from the main map let's see if
it'll let me it's like this tiny no it doesn't look like
they filmed in there that's okay though that's okay i'm
blocking it but um this so if you don't go through the
electric town exit and you come out the other side what if
you're like oh gosh i got lost and then welcome back mint
what is post pandemic akiba like chuo dori has looked like a
ghost town lol on street view recently and 99 of dojin
stores closed what in tarnation is going on there now akiba
is crowded as heck maybe maybe in street view it's very not
crowded but oh my gosh it is extremely crowded all the time
very very often so it's definitely not dying which is great
you're definitely not going to see this but I'm a very small
fan teeny tiny yeah unfortunately we Torano did Torano Anna
did close which is so sad but yeah anyway you guys let me
explain if you go through here you'll get back to where
where we saw that mage can made dream in but also in here is
the square enix cafe which they also do like monthly collab
stuff last time i was there they were doing the final
fantasy 7 one but it was busy every single day but certain
so you like needed a reservation but there's also a takeout
menu um which so you can get takeout stuff and also there's
a store which you can just kind of walk into you don't have
to have a reservation at the cafe.
And, but if it's also like a not as popular game that
they're doing or popular property, because sometimes they've
done like Full Metal Alchemist too.
Like a permanent Square Enix Cafe, not a pop-up.
Yeah, it's permanent.
It's permanent.
There's also like some crane games in here.
There's a few restaurants in here as well.
There's a drugstore in here.
It's actually, there's actually quite a lot going on in this
little small space so uh check check it out even though it's
just a tiny tunnel i'm a ceiling fan whoa whoa that's my
sound of a ceiling whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa there's a restaurant up in here oh oh i don't
know what happened i've never stayed at this rem akiba
before but it might be good i don't I'm an average size fan
thank you for being thank you for sharing your averageness
oh I don't usually recommend going to like book offs and
stuff in super crowded places like Akiba but if you're
looking for a book off it's over here by Danka so I don't
know but I've gone in here before I've gotten a couple
things i've been able to find some things that are pretty
cool so thank you you're welcome
um and there's also like some other like uh tourist shops
but not so many over here it's the big this is like this i
always or not always but um sometimes if i'd come to akiba
in the in the mornings that I see a line of people waiting
for the patchy pachinko like lined up right here in the
mornings it's pretty it's pretty like wow they're ready
they're ready to pachinko you'll definitely see this but I'm
like one of those fancy modern high-tech bladeless fans like
a Dyson fan Wow from here you can see pasera We're gonna go
down that way now.
So yeah, this is the tunnel that we would have gone through
if they would have led us.
There's the hotel here.
There's a little, it says ice cream, but it's like, they
have, in the fall and stuff they have like a yaki emo and
stuff like that.
So yummy!
Can I, if I move over just a tiny bit.
A little, just a scooch.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Wait.
I was just going to see if I could zoom in and see the
square.
It's like blocked by the pole, though.
But it's on this side.
It's right over there.
Mr. Duna Doko.
Hold on.
They opened Yostar Shop right in front of the station.
Really?
Wait, when?
Because I know there was a Yostar Shop at...
in the anime Minecraft
I want to Minecraft so bad I want to Minecraft
I want to play block game there's one one there was a sega
obviously but they still do it as gigo which i'm really
happy about um there's one that does like the themed tayaki
i'll show you guys that one later but right now the the
atore is yuru yuri
um if you go in on the second floor on the second floor is
where you can find whatever pop-up shop is going on.
Last year, my cousin was at Akiba and I asked him to get a
few Konami Famicom games at Super Potato, but they were a
bit expensive.
Do you know a place that sells retro games for cheaper?
I know another place.
I can't say it's that much cheaper, though.
And Akiba, because it's kind of really picked over, things
are going to be kind of why is one of the windows empty it's
actually so sad that Akarine is getting blocked by the momoi
doke so this clock is called the momoi doke the momoi clock
momoi clock and it's it's kind of like you know it's been
here for year like decades it's it's always just been like
this symbol of Akiba and it's block block no
yeah the momoi clock so um yeah because uh momoi Haruko um
she kind of like she she would like have she would have
meetings here and um she even has a song about this clock
like Like, it's just, it got moved before.
It was in a different spot.
I don't remember where.
It got moved a little after they did some construction on
the station.
But, yeah.
But also, as you can see, up here, they have, like, a
Uniqlo.
The Idol Master shop is up here, too.
The Idol Master official shop.
Cospa, which, if you don't know, there's several Cospas in
Akiba.
But they also have, like, oh, yeah, three quarters.
If you want a good, like, it's not a, it's not a 100 yen
store, but it's like three coins.
It's like 300 yen.
Everything is really high quality and nice.
Even though most of it's 300 yen.
Momoi Haruko, Queen of Akiba.
Yeah.
But yeah, there's also a bookstore up here too.
And the Kaspa is selling, like, recently.
they've been selling these like um last time I went I think
it was quintessential quintuplets but it was like little
cakes and stuff too so I thought that was kind of neat I
didn't I didn't grab one but um you have some other
electronic things here uh wait am I trapped again uh oh wait
forward forward uh oh wait oh here we go here we go And
here, can I go back this way?
There we go.
A little more?
Can I?
No?
Here is Najio Kaikan!
Yeah!
Najio Kaikan!
This is like a big mega otaku building.
There's so many things.
If you want a card shop, here.
want dolls they have not only a zone but they also have um
they also have what's the other one called oh my god my
brain the ones that do doll fees the one that volks thank
you they have volks as well they actually close the cospa
and atore one what that must have been very recent really I
think they're opening a love life shop down the hall from
the I mass store where the cospa used to be wait but they
weren't right next to each other the cospa and the the cospa
and the idol master store were right next to each other are
you sure what how how soon did that happen that must be very
very recently I didn't didn't see it last month did you show
mandarake man Drake no I haven't we haven't gotten down
there yet but yeah so this is like everything there's also
right here is a cute little gifts like a it says gift store
gift shop like a good omiyage presents souvenirs shimarin
yeah so I definitely recommend you could spend forever here
There's K-books, there's Ami Ami.
Like I said, there's a card shop, card shops.
There's just regular figure places.
There's like an airsoft place too.
So lots and lots of stuff.
And of course, there are big umamusume billboard right here.
And then they play like ads and stuff here, which is kind of
fun to see.
It's very...
Look at this.
This view is so...
Akihabara, right?
Yeah.
Umapyoi!
Uh-huh.
Let's see.
Uh, this is Pachinko.
In case you were like, Wow, railgun.
Ooh, Madoka.
Ooh, Evangelion.
It's just Pachinko.
Pachinko, Pachinko.
Oh my god.
This is so funny.
Do you want...
Do you know...
For people, don't say if you know what this is.
stores but do you want to guess what this what this line is
for oh my gosh this is so funny because it even looks kind
of early in the in the day because there's not so many
people so there's already people lining up for this crepes
okay good figures mm-hmm ramen mm-hmm
cards mm-hmm yeah like some of even some of the start stores
aren't even open like here's another
pancakes oh good guess good guess this is for ensemble stars
as you can see this is the ensemble star store and so um in
the past you used to have a you used to need a reservation
to get in but i think nowadays you can just kind of go but
this screen right here is always playing ensemble stars so
these people are up early in the morning For On Stars.
But it's right here.
I think it's this one.
But it's right in the same building as Gamers.
Which is, of course, an iconic store in Akihabara.
This is, you know, Digico from DigiCara and everything.
So the line is for pretty boys.
Yeah.
Look at them.
They're so excited to get their merch.
Um, and what is this?
What is this?
I actually don't know.
Sorry, I'm a fake fan.
Kunoichi, Tzubaki.
Mm, forehead anime.
I can tell.
Why does it look like Takagi-san?
Is it the same artist?
She looks like Takagi-san.
And forehead.
Oh, it is the same artist.
I've never seen it, though.
But sometimes they do, like, say there's a new single coming
out for an anime.
They will, typically, the singer will have, like, an an
event at gamers on the top floor and they do other like
collaboration stuff too sometimes if like a concert was
released if you go um and like go shopping you can see like
the say the costume that the idol wore or the say you wore
at the at the concert so it's still fun to stop by and i
like to go in there and check out what's kind of new
sometimes so earlier someone asked where Can you still hear
the Made Dreamin theme song played in Akiba?
And it's this one.
This one is always playing the Made Dreaming theme song.
So if you walk by here, you'll definitely hear it.
My long last Oshi used to do regular shows up there.
Wait, who was it?
Who was it?
24-hour soba, huh?
Yes, this is Fuji soba.
which is a chain actually but they are 24 hours so if you're
in akiba maybe you are like staying here um in a hotel or
something and you're like oh my gosh i'm so hungry but i
don't want combini food there is a fuji soba here that is 24
hours so um and it's a chain so if you're somewhere else and
you're like oh fuji soba someone from sound or an ah don't
want to go into understandable
Yeah, but they don't just have soba.
They think they have like other stuff too, curry, things
like that.
And they do take out.
This place right here used to be the Volks building.
Used to be just a bunch of...
This one's really depressing to explain.
It used to be the Volks building.
And it used to have like a bunch of, you know, just anime
figure shops and collabs.
stores and things like that unfortunately that's not the
case anymore but and it was empty for years it was empty for
a very long time until recently until very recently where um
where um it is now a drugstore so it's not empty anymore at
least because it was really depressing walking by it and it
just being all boarded up and nothing going on but it's now
it's now a drugstore so it's a little depressing um but yeah
and by drugstore i mean like you know you can get medicine
and things i love drugs legal or illegal but i mean yeah
There's one right over here, there's a Matsukio!
Right there!
You don't need another drugstore right across the street.
Ah, zanen.
Over here.
Oh, maybe.
Uh, hold on, maybe if I go out a little bit more.
We transported back to 2013!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, you can see it.
It was so...
Wait.
Yes.
I was like, wait, where am I right now?
We transported.
Wait, see more dates.
July 2022.
There we go.
Sorry, I'm trying to keep this as updated as possible for
now so that we...
I can give a more authentic toll, a more accurate toll,
right?
time travel.
Can you see the Sega building from here?
You mean the Giggle?
Yes.
Yeah, the Giggles right there.
Down here.
Now we're in 2017.
Now we're in 2015.
We're back in 2015.
Can I change the date again?
Oh, wait, we have September 2nd.
2023 oh my gosh so recent um you have another gigo down here
you have a lamb taro here which is like part yabai store
part um part like other stuff there's just it's just like a
variety of stuff but it's a little little yabai at the lamb
taro top floor.
Yea, it's a little...
All stories yabai.
Part yabai.
Maybe mostly yabai.
But what I wanted to point out here was the Pepper Ranch
because I really like Pepper Lounge.
Pepper Lounge.
Doko desuka.
Right here.
Mother Evers.
Pepper Lounge.
This used to be the only Pepper lunch in akiba but they
recently also opened another one all the way down there but
it's much bigger this one is really small so if you're
craving pepper lunch pepper ranch pepper ranch what does
that add here i don't recognize it though i'm such a fake
fan oh my gosh sorry i don't know anything i don't even know
akiba Oh, it's Bo- Oh, I was like, Oh, it's Bochi the Rock!
I obviously know Bochi's- Wait, you were being serious.
I thought you were kidding and being like, Oh, Bo- What are
you talking about?
That's Bochi the Rock, obviously.
Actually, this is your lie in April.
There's actual Bochi.
The gamer's OnStar.
I like this place, Oh, well, oh, it turned into a- That's
right.
I forgot it turned into a trading card, but it used to be
kind of like a pop-up store and sometimes they would be like
there's another one there's another place that does this in
Akiba but it used to be like a one time it was a pop-up
store for like say you branded headphones so like if you're
just like oh I want O'Gurayui to speak in my ear yukana you
could get that but there's another place like that last time
I when they were selling eye cuts headphones.
But now it's trading card.
Okay.
I don't even think I'm ready to talk about it.
Over here.
Hey, get out of my way.
Get out of my way.
Thank you.
Imagine an anime about someone trapped in Akiba who keeps
getting transported to different ears as they walk around.
That would be actually so awesome.
Right here is Manse Bashi.
Manse Bashi Bridge.
Which is just iconic bridge in Akiba.
You have the train that runs here.
You have some restaurants here.
You just have a really beautiful view of Akiba here.
This used to be a famous famous Katsu place, but it's now...
Not just Katsu, like a famous...
It's just like a famous...
How do I say?
Meat?
I'm so depressed about it.
But...
I believe they opened like a...
Not... I mean, obviously this doesn't exist anymore, but
they opened a smaller scale store with sandwiches.
from what I understand so
yeah had the meats
they did have katsusando though they did have like some they
had like a store down here where you could get some stuff
and then the restaurant obviously
akiba is changing but also so much of akiba is still the
same so it's not so bad it's bad but not so bad which way
should we go down do i want to go down chulo dori first or
no we can go down here so over here
right here is where you find the grand blue fantasy cafe
it's if you see the pasela wait you can't really heal then i
think i showed it earlier uh You can see it from over here
too.
Oh, come on, tree!
Come on, tree!
Here, here, here.
The Pasella...
The Pasella Resorts?
This is also...
Not just a pop-up.
But I believe they also do other cafe pop-ups as well.
Like one time they had...
Oh, here you can see.
What is that?
Is that Kochi Usa?
Am I dumb?
It is Kochi Usa?
Okay, okay.
I was like, wait.
I don't want to be...
I don't want to say I'm being wrong.
But yeah, they do other pop-ups in here.
It's definitely worth checking out what they're doing.
Because I believe also this is the Monster Hunter place,
too.
so there's like there's a lot going on here all the time um
so it's the monster hunter cafe the grand blue cafe and then
what other other pop-up cafes as well oh see oh yeah yeah
yeah manhan on the third floor um so yes um there's also uh
pasela is a karaoke place it's like a chain a chain karaoke
one and it's not this isn't even the only one in akiba but
um they are known for their Toast boxes.
These.
They're so yummy.
So, so good.
The toast cafe.
Yeah, yeah.
You can get them.
You can order them while you're like.
While you're singing.
But this is not just.
It says like famous dessert in Akiba.
That's a lie.
You can get the honey toast.
At any Pase.
Maybe they do specialized ones here.
But like you can get the honey toast anywhere.
and what it is is it's like it's it's it's like four pieces
of toast that make a box and then they put like ice cream
and fruit and stuff inside the box inside the inside the
toast so it's really yummy and um um also here is a theater
called parms which is a event It's basically just a live,
it's like a theater, not a live house.
It's a theater, which this group called Kamen Joshi, they
play there every day.
So if you want to go see some idols and you're just like,
well, I don't know where to go.
You can always come here and they will be doing a live show.
So it's pretty fun.
Every day.
This is some collab cafe.
But I can't read it.
I have no idea what a or orsia a orsia I can't read it I saw
it down here too all I can see is cafe
a final fantasy 14 aorzia is final fantasy 14 stuff thanks
guys oh my gosh how she's not even qualified to give this to
her why is she even giving us the tour right now she doesn't
even know she doesn't even go here if you come down this way
a little bit too
if you are a fan whoa if you're a fan of love live which
maybe these guys are too this is actually one of the parks
that they visit in love live why are there why are there Why
is there such a big group of...
I say park, but there's like just a couple benches in here.
Why is there...
Why is there such a big group of people?
What's going on?
Those are definitely love libraries.
It almost looks like this guy has like some anime, like
something on...
Some, some like...
Maybe it's Oshi.
But yeah.
When was this taken?
September 2023?
If you were there, September 2023, I'm so...
Is that you?
I'm just so...
What is going on?
I'm so curious.
But yeah.
In store, meow.
Let's see.
I'm trying to decide how I want to go about this.
There's some other stuff back there.
I know that's like the most vague phrasing ever.
We won't go down the street yet.
Let's go back to Chuo Dori.
Wasn't one where Nico's apartment got torn down and made
into a park?
No.
This park was already there.
they are they sit in it in love life in that park like in
the um in the original love life so but i don't i don't
actually know where nico's apartment was i'll be honest i
actually don't know
so yay this this main street here like this this street that
goes down is called it's like Chuo Dori it's like like I
said the main street so if we go down a little here this is
where we started hold on I'm just gonna go down a little bit
this is this is Akiba station down here just to get you a
little bit oriented there's that hotel there's Radio Kaikan
there's gamers there's the main dream in so this is all that
if you turn around here you have oh you have let me move
that a little bit you have ono den which is like a famous
this ono den has been here for ever as well in akihabara
it's one of those like staple um electronic stores that has
been here forever and um but in in the ono den building um
there's a book off oh no sorry the book off is the one that
i pointed out earlier uh there is a oh my gosh there is a
cosplay store there is uh what else is there um i'm trying
to remember I think this is where I think it was a pop-up
store though I couldn't remember but they did have like a
blue archive no not a blue archive I'm thinking of somewhere
else they had a they had just like a general dogen artist
pop-up which I didn't get to go to I was busy I was in a
hurry and I didn't get to go is that to who yes but there's
like a Toho corner in the store I'm the worst at describing
stuff one thing I do want to point out here that I like to
come here for though is the cure made cafe which if you're
wanting a made cafe that's not like your super high energy
made cafe just one it doesn't even have a table charge it's
very relaxed and chill it's the cure made cafe they are
always doing a collaboration with some sort of anime or game
um so before you go i would check the schedule because you
know something stop stop looking over here stop stop looking
over here stop stop look stop looking no no no take us to b1
what what you'll never go to the second floor.
You'll never go there.
Why do you think it's only one floor in men's goods is two
floors?
Actually, I'll also never go there because I'm not allowed,
I think.
I don't think I'm allowed on these floors.
I think it's only for guys to go to.
Which makes me even more curious.
I want to go even more now.
lingerie oh yeah i mean you can get that at like don quixote
too and stuff like they sometimes sell like really sexy
costumes and um um i'll be honest i've i've been in m's but
i've never been in love mercy because i'm shy i've been in
m's before love mercy has been here forever it's also like
one of those stores that's just been here in akiba forever
but i've never gone because i'm i'm shy okay i'm shy but i i
went to m I don't know.
Maybe because I went with some friends, you know.
Love Mercy is the same as Emzo.
Yeah, but I went with friends before.
Anyways, let me continue my wholesome talking about the Cure
Maid Cafe.
Oh, this is it right here.
Basically, you'll go up the escalator a couple times, a
couple floors, and you'll arrive on one floor, and...
You're up to...
Thank you!
What do you mean, Q?
What do you mean?
The...
Stop, stop.
The floor...
The floor with the...
With the...
With the main cafe has...
Stop it!
It has...
Stop it right now!
Do you want this tour or not?
Huh?
Oh my god.
ARK!
Thank you for that.
I got super.
Loving the updated Akiba Tour.
Your original stream was what got me hooked on your channel
in the first place.
Glad you're back.
Thank you!
I hope one day I could...
Well, you know, not myself walking around in Akiba, but if
someone walked around Akiba went for me and I got to talk
about it and stuff on stream.
I hope one day I can do something like that.
It'd be really fun, I think.
Oh, what was I saying?
Oh, you go here on your, you go up the escalator a couple
floors.
In front of you on the right will be Kiramade Cafe.
Across from it will be the Cospa.
To the left of it will be an extension of the Cospa.
It's like a different
is also the cosplay store.
Let's get out of here.
I'm...
Minolinski Cafe.
Yes!
Oh, yes.
Pasha Min.
Thank you.
Yes, this cafe...
The cafe...
Cure Cafe is the cafe that Kotori worked at in...
In Love Live.
So it's also a...
You can also get like...
Love Live Cure made goods.
there as well Wolfman, thanks for the tiny gifted, thank you
chat broke Yeah, you did break
You helped inspire me to push through and get my game on
Steam Oh my gosh Entire journey has been heckin' awesome And
I love popping into streams Fight me
Okay, I'll fight you Congrats!
I'm broken.
Let's see.
Matsukio is a chain.
It's nothing special.
It's not Akiba special or anything.
It's just a drugstore.
And you can get skincare there.
Here's like if you're looking for oh I didn't point them out
over there either.
But if you're looking for some of like those small
electronic stores that are like very, you know original
akihabara lots in there um one thing at one place i would do
want to point out over here as you can see from the sign
this is a mid cafe i really like the isekai mid cafe um i
like this cosplayer her name is shio she's very cute as go
sue thank you for the vibe give the thank you but if you
want to go to the isekai made cafe the entrance is right
here and it's just right here on the second floor right here
so yeah it's on the second floor it's very cute i like the
theme there um oh oh wait yeah here they are the um the
other electronic stores and stuff like that lots lots in
this building in general so um oh my gosh so cute the yuri
yuri it's so cute this is side of Akiba Station?
So if you come out the other way, can we walk this way?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
For real?
Can we walk this way for real?
Will let us in?
Will we be transported to nighttime with all the guys
standing around?
Okay, we're going.
Wait, is it, it's Idol Master now?
And Laplace, Laplace Sama, what is the, um, it's like
Shadowverse or something?
What is that?
Oh.
Yes, it is.
What's so funny is...
So yeah, see?
We're back at Akiba Station.
Woohoo!
It's so funny.
These advertisements for like...
Oh gosh.
Every time that I've gone back to Akiba...
They're Arknights here, but right now they're usually Blue
Archive advertisements.
So...
I guess...
I guess Blue Archive took over
But this is the other side Oh remember when we were trying
to go to school This is the UDX building It's the school
that the girls The rival girls go to and love live There's a
bunch of restaurants and stuff in there Over here is the
Tamashi Nation store Which I recommend checking out 100%
Because they sometimes they'll have like um how do i
describe it it's not like a pop-up it's like almost it
almost feels like a museum like they'll have like uh like
sometimes it'll be like an exhibit of macross and it'll show
like a bunch of their old macross figures and the the the um
timeline of macross and stuff like that um things like that
so um they'll have like like one time i went and there was
the um
that costume that guy wears i can't remember anything today
i'm so sorry and it's like it's like the black straps across
his body um rip the Gundam cafe yeah unfortunately the
Gundam cafe and the akb48 cafe used to be here they're no
longer here it is now the Hot Limit!
Thank you, Ghoststalker.
Yes, TM Revolution.
They had the costume.
They had the TM Revolution, like the Hot Limit song costume
there.
So it was, I was just like, whoa, I'm pretty sure I have a
picture somewhere.
There's a coffee.
There's a coffee cafe here.
There's also a revolving sushi place that has been here
forever.
It's very small.
Um, but if you are like, there's a sushi dough, like right
over here.
Um, and a hamazushi.
Wait, is that still there?
The hamazushi?
Actually, I'm not sure.
I don't remember.
But if you're wanting a sushi place, and those, um, the
sushi dough, and maybe the hamazushi are busy, there's also
a sushi place.
That's a rotating sushi.
Right there!
So, the atore.
Oh yeah, here, there's the sushi though.
It's kind of in the basement, right?
Oh, wait, where'd it go?
Is it over here?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, it's in the basement.
So, let another drugstore.
They're everywhere, the drugstores.
Why are you...
Wait, you're...
You're...
You're an otaku, that galah um giggle here um this one has
like uh the i'm pretty sure it's this one i don't i'm not i
don't think the other ones have it as much but this one has
like the gundam pods if i remember correctly i don't sorry
not You can correct me if I'm wrong about that.
But, uh...
The Gundam Tide Pods, exactly.
Um, let's actually go down here.
Because this is the Gigo.
I mentioned earlier how...
Um...
It is this road, right?
Hold on.
Let me get my bearings.
Yes, it's right here.
It's not open right now.
But this is where, um, they do...
You can kind of see it.
They do the...
Is that it?
Actually, no.
I think that's K.
I think that's a reflection of KFC.
Never mind.
Wait.
Is that?
It says KFC.
It says KFC, but the sign...
Is it reflecting this one?
It's reflecting KFC, but this is not the KFC.
That's kind of confusing.
This is where they do the Tayaki is what I was trying to
say.
So it's like themed Tayaki, which is kind of fun.
Um, so it like, uh, um, I'm trying to think of what it was.
It's been Love Live before.
Um, uh, it's been one week since you're looking at me.
They have Hollow Live 5th gen right now.
Oh, really nice.
Nice, nice.
Sega Notayaki.
Um, unfortunately now it's Gigo Notayaki.
But...
Um, yes, they did do Sonic before.
That was the other one I was thinking of.
So.
Um, you can, you can get some Tayaki here.
Yes, ah, I remember the Persona 3 one.
Yes, yes, yes.
And Vispo.
Mm-hmm.
Well, I don't know if the Vispo, the Tayaki was Vispo.
But, uh, there's an anime, anime, anime, anime.
An Anisong cafe here called Guild.
I know friends that I've been, I personally have not, so I
can't tell you how it works.
I mean, there's just hobby shops everywhere.
Like, I haven't been everywhere, so I'm so sorry.
You know, I'm a fake fan.
Not qualified to give this tour.
But, um, there's also another, there's actually several
Annie Song cafes and bars in Akiba.
Um, another account called Alchemist, which, um, is close.
closer to Yodobashi Camera, actually.
That one's Alchemist.
And then, what was the other one?
It was another one that I also haven't been to before, but
my friend recommended it, so I'm gonna go next time.
I can't remember it, though.
How dare the tour guide has not been into literally every
store.
Also, this Gigo, the last time I came, I get...
might be new or it might have been a one-time thing but i
think they do like um there's crane games on these floors
and then on the top floor there was an event space where
they had a steinsgate um a steinsgate collab uh and they had
like little standies and they had exclusive merch and um i
got this super duper cute block calendar that i have on my
desk now it's so cute um so But, you know, Gigo is doing
well, and I can appreciate that.
It feels like almost like Sega never left, almost.
Because they're still at it.
They're still at it.
Even though it's so sad.
And there's a KFC here.
If you are craving the Kentucky Fried Chicken.
That's here.
Here, this is a...
You can get a...
I was going to say you can get some...
some uh some visual novels here because traders too
lots of visual novels there tv game i love tv game now this
street down here is what um my friends and i like to call
nugget bridge because it is so packed with every night down
this street is so packed with maids.
There will be maids trying to stop you at every stop.
They'll be like do you want to come to our maid cafe?
Oh, how does a ninja girl maid cafe sound?
Oh, do you want to come to our maid?
Right here?
I don't know if they do it so much anymore, but this is
where this is where maid dreaming is one of the maid
dreaming locations is.
And sometimes the girls will I don't, like I said, I don't
know if they do it so much anymore, but they used to come
out onto this little, um, onto this little balcony and like
Dance and like kind of try and entice people from above Like
a real angel Ninja made girls.
Yeah, you get so many different kinds of girls here I was
like, I've seen a military type girl.
I've seen a ninja girl.
I've seen
my mind is blank did we find the chubby girl maid cafe yet
no i'll take you there i'll take you there don't worry don't
worry patience patience patience i think oh when i was when
we um watched uh some some some time ago we watched the
couple streams ago we watched the opening for the akiba maid
war anime i'm pretty sure this is what the street that I
think it was because like I said like there's the Kotobuki
awe I think this is the one that it's supposed to be I might
be wrong though but I think this is the one I was like wait
a second
also Mellon books on Mellon books the entrance is actually
on the oh on the other side you can go through this is an
arcade you can cut through it or you can just walk around
here and i'll show you um but akiba all akibaos are also all
over akiba they're um electronic stores they have really
cheap electronic stuff so um yeah you can see the balcony
here it's very cute and here we have a kotobukiya yahoo
kotobukiya is so so great why is everything closed how early
did they film this i wonder um The Kotobukiya on the first
floor, you can get like Final Fantasy stuff.
There's a little bit of Hollow Life stuff.
There's a big Niji-sanji section.
On the second floor, there's...
What I really love about Kotobukiya is getting the stuff
like for storing my figures.
It's like...
Oh yeah, the Tales of stuff, yeah.
Though the Tales of...
They used to have like a really dedicated Tales of section.
I don't think that is around anymore.
um all the vtuber stuff on the third floor now oh really
that must have been actually i don't think i went the last
time i oh yeah there remember how i said places in akiba or
places in japan open late and close early opens at 12 opens
at 12 and then opens i mean closes probably at like seven
gosh it's so early so open so late hololive on the top Oh,
thanks for letting me know.
It drives me mad.
Me too.
It's so frustrating.
Because of course you're wanting to make the most out of
your day and visit the most places as possible, but it kind
of makes it hard when they don't open until noon.
But yeah, I like to get the stuff like they have the stand.
these for your figures.
They have like acrylic boxes and stuff for storing your
figures.
They got a lot of stuff in here.
I really like it.
They got stuff for model kits and everything like that
paints.
I mean, they're not the only place, of course.
Oh, excuse me.
They're not the only place, of course, but sorry, just going
back to the main road real quick.
If you go in through here, this is where Melon Books is.
You'll pass some crane games on the right, and there's a
couple of gotcha pon that Always steal your money!
Melon Books!
Fix your gacha pawn, please!
I had to try, I tried, oh my god, I tried helping some poor
guy who, who got his money stuck in the gacha pawn.
And it happened to me and my friends some time ago too.
And like, we kind of like just bam, bam, bam on the gacha a
little bit.
Just a little bit.
And it eventually came out.
and they're not like super cheap either they're like 400 yen
they were like some blue archive uh keychain like little
acrylic acrylic keys and i was just like i was like trying
to help the guy i was just like uh i was like here let me
try this thing is eating my money before too and i was like
i was like but it was like when i when it happened to me
before it was kind of late at night so there weren't so many
people around so we were like okay with like kind of hitting
the the maybe it's broken because so many people keep
hitting it because it keeps eating their money but anyway do
not use the gotcha pon there because it's actual gotcha it's
you might just get nothing so don't don't do it even if you
see the blue archive or the genshin impact don't do it i in
the end i couldn't even help the guy i was like i'm so sorry
i i i i can't get it out he was like it's okay but I really
tried to help him out sorry guy nah I'd still do it last
order films thank you for the Tony gifted thank you but um
yeah so if you're tempted I recommend not to be tempted
don't even don't even look that way sorry but we keep
skipping some stuff because i'm going everywhere this is the
gigo just to get you guys up to speed there's the isekai
made cafe over there is the train station um there's an
arcade here um mansebashi bridge down there yeah ramen shop
here um more more game store stuff here
here it's smaller i just recommend going to the tamashi
nation's bigger place this place is always there's always so
many this is one of those like um stores that like the tour
the foreigner tour groups go on and so like um there always
is like so many people like that because they meet up here
you know yeah it's a tourist trap it's one of those tourist
traps that somehow made it through the
but yeah um so if you go through here oh wait it's open now
oh you can see so yeah um if you go here like i said the
gachapon will be on the right there will be a stairs down
into melon books and then there's some stairs up into the uh
into the arcade that is right here so it's all connected
it's kind nice hey hey wait who's it why are we saying hey
hey hey hey hey what are you doing thank you for the pink
thank you thank you oh akitabura hey oh hey
hey pour one out for me i found the namco noir clone arcade
cabinet at an amazing price locally but I measured it and it
won't fit through my door.
Time to get rid of the door.
I don't know what else to tell you.
Hmm.
Here's Akiba Culture Zone, but also, someone mentioned it
earlier.
Here's Super Potato.
The...
It's like, you know, one of the...
it was the retro store until it kind of like got it's still
fun to visit though you know even though some things become
like a little overrun they're still very fun to visit you
know it's still fun to see the history but if you're going
be prepared because the stairs are very steep and very small
and inside the store too it's i mean inside of a lot of
stores in japan it's just very very very jam-packed and
crowded um like even when there's not a lot of people it's
just so it's so tiny in there um the but on the third floor
third floor fourth floor is where they have snake and i go
there every time i'm back in japan and i take a picture with
them i take a picture with snake every time in there i often
go there to buy candy
The snake for sale.
No.
So sad.
He's not.
I never even noticed the candy.
I was just going to see snake.
Cute.
Here is Akiba.
Oh, wait.
What date is it?
Whoa.
Wait a second.
2022.
But backstage.
Pass was already...
Backstage Pass was already closed by then.
Like maybe they just didn't get rid of the sign.
This is Akiba Culture Zone.
Which I'm just gonna show you from the back here real quick.
They have a ton of stores in here.
This is where all the maids will try to bombard you with...
Hey, come to my cafe.
Hey, how does this cafe sound?
Hey, how does that cafe sound?
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Trying to get a good view of Culture Zone real quick.
Hold on.
Maybe here?
This is good.
So Culture Zone is this big building.
It's really awesome.
The first floor is Dashinban.
Oh, no, sorry.
The second floor is Dashinban.
I think the first floor is also Dashinban, though, isn't it?
Yeah.
First and second floor, Dashinban.
the first floor is more like regular anime goods and then
the second floor is like dojin and a little bit more yabai
stuff thank you still not as much as a as an overpriced scam
as mashak so maybe who knows but um yeah you can get figures
and anime like you know I say anime goods there's like
youtuber stuff down here too but the more yabai stuff is on
the second floor if you're looking for that.
The third floor is like a mishmash of a ton of different
stores.
You have like the Trio is an idol store, which I like to go
frequent.
You have card shops, you have figure shops, you have a lot
of different kind of stuff.
Same on the fourth floor.
The fifth floor is the at-home cafe.
One of them in Akihabara.
there's this one, there's a building of at-homes right over
here, and then there's one at Don Quixote.
I honestly, this one is the biggest and the nicest, I
believe because it's the newest.
But what's at-home cafe?
It's a maid cafe.
I've been to this at-home.
How long?
How long of a wait?
Did you wait for?
Because...
what's iTube studio I'll get to that once again um because
this at home cafe I've tried going so many times oh my gosh
mini scouters thank you for the 50 gifted thank you so much
thank you so much I've been I've tried to go to this at home
cafe several times now several times but the weight has
always been like two hours it is ridiculous i went to the
one over here um which is also seven floors and the weight
there was about an hour and a half
actually no it was more like an hour it was more like an
hour yeah but it was still very very very long time um which
we probably should have done a reservation but we just
didn't um yeah how long is the wait for cure made like zero
minutes you can usually just i've never had a wait i've
always just been able to walk up frog welcome to membership
thank you
You know, at home cafe, I would recommend probably going to
the Don Quixote one because that one seems to always have
the smallest line for if you're wanting to wait.
But it's also, I'm pretty sure, also pretty small.
I've been there like just a handful of times.
And I'll show you Don Quixote later.
The one in Akiba.
Since it's so packed, is it expensive?
it's it's really just high quality like um the kind of
experience that you get is really high quality so um you
know it's really popular with guys and girls with like all
sorts of people and then of course because it's like one of
the more popular maid cafes it's also very popular with with
foreigners so um you just get like a ton of people going
there all the time so if you go to at home cafe prepare to
wait unless you do a reservation
but is high quality good for maid cafes I think it depends
on what kind of experience you want at the top here is this
place called iTube studio it used to be an idol cafe that I
actually auditioned for called Backstage Pass, which I made
it into, but then I turned it down because I wanted to focus
more on my studies.
But now, as you can see here, the sign was over here.
Hold on.
Meow.
Right here.
This was Backstage Pass.
This is Horiuchi Kaori.
Oh, gosh.
What was her name?
There's Moyazu.
She's a really popular, she's a really popular mukbang
YouTuber.
She eats so much food.
She eats so much food!
Um Oh my gosh, what was your name?
Was it Yui?
I don't remember.
But yeah, they don't have my Oshi up here.
But that's okay, I think she had already graduated.
And so it was this, at the cafe, actually produced by the
same person that produced uh does she eat shiroko she has
she has she has oh my gosh yeah she has she did a video
recently i mean shirako no wait shiroko shiroko from
Shiroko No, don't eat Shiroko from Blue Archive
What was I saying?
Oh, it was produced by the same person that produced It was
Morning Musume project so um yeah their songs were very like
pretty uh what's the word like hello project like and um
unfortunately it's closed now which is so sad because i
would visit very often and it turned into this i tube studio
which was like an amalgamation of backstage And iTunes
Studio, which was just a cafe of YouTubers, I never went
because I was so confused by it.
I did not understand.
It was just a cafe where you can go and talk to YouTubers or
girls that were wanting to be popular YouTubers.
It was very weird.
And the inside of the cafe used to be so iconic for
backstage.
And then they tore it all apart for this ugly, like, it
looked like a Mac store.
um but itube studio has also since shut down so so we don't
even have i don't know um i don't know what will pop up
there next i'll be on the lookout i suppose oh you were
telling us about how you're cute enough to get accepted into
an idol group no no oh my gosh my audition for it was so it
was so embarrassing um i i uh they actually had it not at
the cafe itself um it was like at some separate building
which i might be able to find probably not though it was a
long time ago um but i went and um the guy the guy that was
like interviewing some of us he was just like wow a
foreigner and i was And he was like asking me how I got into
backstage and stuff like that.
I had seen them at an idol show and really started to like
them.
But I also did like some dance covers of some backstage
songs.
So they were like, whoa.
She really likes it.
She already knows the choreography.
So I showed him that.
And then they took us.
He was like showing the other people though in my videos and
I was really embarrassed.
But then we go to the actual like audition part which was
three people sitting in a dance studio.
Like you know there was the mirrored walls and everything.
And we all sat along the wall and they called us up one by
one and they asked us to sing something.
like, okay, and I was like, I've never done an audition
before, especially in Japan.
I've never done any sort of audition like this.
I've never done an audition in Japan.
I've never auditioned for an idol group, so I was like,
super duper nervous.
Acapella?
Yes, acapella.
And, um, so I was just like, okay, I'm just gonna follow
what the other girls do.
And unfortunately, I could not follow what the other girls
did because they called me first and I was like okay and so
I stand up and I'm standing in the middle of the room and
they asked me some questions and they're just like they
asked me about like dancing and singing and just you know
why I wanted to join backstage and I was like this and this
and this and that and that and that and then they were like
okay now sing something for us.
And I was like, um, anything?
Sorry, I'm cringing right now.
I'm cringing right now so bad.
I don't know how I got it.
Because they were like, yeah, anything.
And
I don't even, I just go, oh, oh, oh, oh, and they were like,
thank you, you can sit down.
And then, I'm, like, sitting there, like, okay, I hope I did
that right.
And then the next girl goes up, and they ask her the, like,
similar questions.
And then they're like, okay, sing something for us.
And she has a whole dance and song prepared, and she's just,
like, sitting there.
the song, the actual, she's actually singing, she's actually
singing a song with words and and a melody and like doing a
dance to go along with it.
And I was like, ah, it's in that moment I felt everything
drain from my face and I was like, I was like oh that's what
they meant I don't know why at the moment I thought that
they just wanted to hear a little bit of my you actually
sang Hamtaro didn't you?
That would have been probably better than what I did I just
sat there I was like I messed up I messed up I messed up and
then when I got the email that was like we got you in I was
like like what how how did i pass part of me part of me a
little bit regrets uh not joining because it probably would
have been a good experience to um to join but like i said i
wanted to focus on my studies and another part was i was so
nervous i was i had no confidence in my japanese like that i
Oh my gosh, I'm going to get yelled at every day at work
because they're going to say, they're going to be like, why
didn't you understand?
And I'll be like, go man, no stop.
But it's okay.
It was still an interesting experience being able to, being
evil.
Being able to even attempt an audition for a idol group.
Well, it wasn't an idol group.
an idol cafe, being evil.
Anyway, this is an Akiba tour, everybody.
So sorry about that little tangent.
We have a figure shop here.
There's so many.
If I point out every figure shop in Akiba, we'll be here
forever.
Let's go down here a little bit.
This is the...
You can't see it.
This is the other at-home cafe.
It's all these floors.
All of these floors are at-home cafe.
So it's kind of cool.
There's a gamer lounge down here.
You have yellow submarine, which is just like a hobby shop.
You have trading cards.
You have the ami-ami store here as well.
Gamers only.
They have, they sell, it's like a, It's like a...
What's the word?
They have like monitors, gaming monitors and stuff like
that.
Checking my feet at how cute she is.
You cannot stop me talking.
What do you mean?
Why?
What do you mean by that?
I'll be honest, I've never had a reason to go into this
building.
There's like one of those other tourist spots here, like
those tourist stores.
a bunch of luggage that's all i know but i've never had a
reason to go into this building so i don't actually really
know what's all in isn't it looks like just trading cards so
yeah let's see um so here just to get you guys caught up to
speed this is chuo dori this is the main road if we go back
here a little bit um there's oh actually this is the other
giggle.
There's another giggle down there.
This one is the giggle that has the cafe in it.
Wait.
Is it this one?
Is it Sango?
Sango clan?
Or is it the one down there?
I think it's this one.
I'm pretty sure it's this one.
It's the one that has the cafe in it as well.
Yeah, collab cafe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, um, usually though these require a reservation.
At least they used to in the past.
I haven't been to one in a long time.
But it's an arcade and also that last time I was here, there
was a Vespo.
Vespo collab cafe and stuff.
Mulan, Mulan is just another, I'd say touristy store, but
it's really just like used figures and things like that.
You have a Yoshinoa, which is Gyu Don.
You have a Gogokare.
Um...
Uh, there's nothing really over here.
I'm gonna go back down this way, though.
So here's the Kotobuki app.
Oh, yeah.
Esports Lounge!
It says it right there.
There you go.
Esports Lounge.
I wish it was open, though.
I wish she could see inside.
Oh, wait, maybe from here.
Oh, just kidding.
Here.
If I'm going too fast, just let me know.
If you're like, Mint, I can't see.
Why?
Always someone.
It looks cool, though, I think.
I like, it looks cool in there.
I've always wanted to go to this place because it's like a
ghost, a ghost-themed, like a Chinese ghost themed cafe.
Maybe I'll go next time.
Sometimes I'm worried because sometimes they're less cafe
and more bar like.
And those two places, one, tend to be more expensive.
And two, I don't really drink, so I'm just kind of like,
what will I get?
What will I get?
Mmm!
Yangxi.
like these billboards that are all like different types of
cafes so you have this one which this one I've always I'm
gonna go this to this one next time because hold on sorry
I'm skipping ahead a little bit oh wait hold on no no there
we go can you see it from here yeah it's all like all this
foresty everything up here it's all these it's like this
foresty like it looks looks so cool in there.
Witch's Garden.
But you can see here, it's 800 yen.
Sorry for the giant arrow.
It's 800 yen for 30 minutes.
Oh wait!
Oh wait, that's soft drink Nomi Hodae.
That's soft drink all you can drink.
Wait, yeah.
All you can drink, soft drink.
I can't see the... There's a course here.
I thought that was the table charge.
Oh, maybe not.
Alcohol Nomi Hodae is...
But 800 yen for 30 minutes how much are you drinking how
much even soft drinks I don't think I can get through even
like three soft drinks in 30 minutes you know that's like
sucking it down I know right I don't think I can get through
so much soft drinks wouldn't be worth it but for the alcohol
it's 1500 yen for 30 minutes I wonder what the table charge
is here There's another maid cafe.
This is kind of a maid cafe building.
I'm so sad because this Lawson used to be, it used to be a
dragon quest themed Lawson and when you go inside it would
go and when you left it would go or it would play another
sound and they played like the dragon quest theme inside and
everything.
But I found, I don't know if it's permanent, but I found
another Shibuya.
Just my last trip and I was like, oh my gosh, did it move
here?
I had never seen it before.
I don't know if it was there before.
They still have one in Shibuya.
Yeah, right?
Was it there before?
Hmm.
Anyway, okay.
I got a little ahead of myself.
Let's head back.
Giving a tour is hard because there's so much.
There's so many roads.
So this is where the chubby used to be it was this building
I believe this is where the chubby girl cafe used ah you can
see it Shangri-La yes but it is not here anymore so if you
put in Shangri-La into Google Maps it might take you here it
is not here anymore so do not come over here I will show you
where the new location is I'll show you where It still
exists.
Stop saying no.
It still exists.
It's just not in this location.
It moved.
But yeah.
Let's see.
Down here is some more maid cafes, as you can see.
Here.
There's a whole building of them.
There are maid cafes everywhere.
Oh, Akihama are so perfect.
There's a Coco's restaurant down here, which is just a...
Just a family restaurant, but they have...
They have quesadillas.
And here, if you see the hello storage, that means you've
reached Akiba Zetai Ryiki, which is one of my favorite maid
cafes.
It's super duper cute.
The girls are very cute.
The performances are always so good.
So I recommend Zetai Ryiki very much.
I love their uniforms.
Me too.
There's also more stuff down this street, but we'll go down
here later.
We'll go down here later.
So many maids, I know.
Oh, actually here.
Oh, oh.
This place is a Warhammer store.
Which I was so shocked to see.
I was like, I messaged Matara immediately.
I was like, Matara, there's a warhammer store in Akiba.
And she was like, yeah, I know.
I was like, you knew?
You knew something about Akiba that I didn't.
But it's right next to Akiba Culture Zone.
So, uh...
Matara knows more about Akiba than me!
Yeah, but,
um...
Yeah.
Um, I've never been in, because I don't know anything about
Warhammer.
It also says it's a cafe.
I'm more curious about the cafe than anything.
Let's see, which way do we...
Let's go down the main street a little bit, and then I'll
show you more of the back street stuff.
Back street stuff.
Alright!
Aw, look at all these people.
Um...
This building here...
sometimes they do events down here um like like game
festivals or really anything i've seen concerts there i've
seen figures there i've seen like thomacy nation stuff stuff
stuff stuff there um yeah lots of stuff there that you can
see sometimes um there's a bick camera here oh yeah
I showed you the other McDonald's by Yodobashi camera.
It was the one, it's over there.
This one's also McDonald's.
Hello, Shibuya.
Hello.
This is the trip.
If you're lost, by the way, the train station is right here.
This is the UDX building that I showed before.
It has some...
Sometimes they do, like, events and promo things here as
well.
Like, I saw a big pop-up for the new Idol Master, the school
Idol Master.
But down here, there's Tomashi Nations.
There's the train station.
We honestly haven't gotten that far at all.
There's so much to see in Akiba, we barely walked like two
feet away from the station.
Um, yeah.
Let's go back to the main road.
You'll see a lot of people like taking pictures of like this
section.
of Akiba it's kind of like iconic for the at home poster and
then this whatever place the the pond shop that I'm always
like it always feels so out of place every time I see it um
and then there's always like a bunch of anime and game signs
it's very it's this this scene is so Akihabara you know yeah
it it always reminds me of Dragon Ball too every time I see
it.
So yeah, BIC camera here, which has lots of great stuff.
BIC camera is not just Akihabara.
You can go anywhere.
Meow.
So this is where the new Vox building is, the one that I
showed earlier that turned into a sad, sad drugstore.
It is now here.
This is where Toranoana was.
So it's kind of sad.
turn into volks um so you have your doll fee stuff you have
a quite a you have a bunch of hobby stuff in there um like
figures just rent just general merch and everything um you
have a title here which do they show it in this picture oh
my gosh it's title wait september it's title pre okay
B it's Taito what do you even call those it's Taito's BC
before clap the clapping so there's these oh I don't want to
say oh they oh they're so annoying there's these stupid
there's oh these stupid fucking things that they put out
there's like three of them oh my god they're so annoying
they're like these They look they look like birds.
The little clappers.
I hate them.
They're so annoying They're so They sit there and they go me
me All all day long and there's why are there three if it
was just one it might be fine But there's three of them and
they just sit there and they're just like me me me me me Oh,
and it's so so Annoyed I hate I hate walking past every
time.
I'm like, Taito, what do you, why did you put those out?
They're so annoying.
They, I think they talk.
I just don't know what they're saying because I try to
drain, I try to, I try to just tune them out.
They're so, so.
They're like, yeah, they're like, I don't even know.
Hold on, let me see if I can find a picture.
Taito Arcade, Taito Station Akihabara.
I don't even know what to call them though.
Like, I have to find a really recent picture.
Because...
They are recent.
They, and they, like, sit on top of the arcade machines.
They...
Let me...
Actually, I can draw a picture of them.
That might be easier.
I'm gonna draw a picture real quick.
One second.
Uh...
Whoa, what the hell?
Oh, there we go.
So, they look like...
Uh...
They look...
They are...
Oh, no.
Whoops, my bad.
This one.
They have, like, this bulbous head and this tiny tube body.
They, like, have their little feet down here.
They look like they could be from Petskop.
And then they have eyes.
Like, beady...
Little stupid beady eyes.
eyes.
And then they have this dumb ass duck beak looking shit.
And then they have arms that do this.
They go over their head.
And they have giant clapping hands.
And they're, they're, they, they're bright red.
Like that.
And all they do, they, they talk, they open their mouths and
And they clap their hands But there's three of them And they
don't shut up
Hey, what's wrong with duck beaks?
Oh, sorry, duck you
They even look annoying I know I want to punch them every
time And they're super loud They are, they're so loud So, I
know one day they'll probably grow on me.
One day, one day I'll like go back to Akiba and they'll be
gone and I'll be like, where's the clappy ducks?
And I'll be so sad.
I'll be like, I'll be like walking by the Taito arcade and
I'll be like, oh, it's so quiet.
And I'll look to the top of the arcade machine with wistful
eyes.
And I'll just imagine them up there greeting me.
I'll just be so sad.
Be like, little clappy man, where did you go?
My eyes will glaze over with tears.
They'll just, they'll be, and I'll like, I'll do like a sad
nod being like, yeah.
Yeah, I hope you're out there clapping in heaven.
Me, me, me, me, me, me.
The fact that I could draw it probably as accurate as I
could from memory just probably goes to oh oh oh oh it goes
to show how much of an impact they've made on my afterlife
truly God okay anyway I could listen to you talk about Akima
forever you're my favorite geography teacher Thank you,
student K-Barn.
They're called Big Clappy.
Wait, actually?
Big Clappy.
Oh my god, you're right now!
Oh my god, no way!
Oh my god.
I already closed out of my picture.
No.
I already closed out of my picture, but please, look.
Okay, I'm gonna get a picture.
I'm going to show you guys a picture to show how accurate my
paint, MS Paint picture was.
Okay, are you guys ready for this?
Are you guys ready to see how accurate this was?
There's no way.
It was exactly spot on, not a single detail off!
I have to buy one now.
I have to buy one, the big crappy.
Oh my gosh, I just realized I don't have my noise gate on.
Big crappy.
I can't.
Seeing that just ruined my day.
Oh my god.
Wait, stop.
Stop.
Lady Gaga.
Sorry, I accidentally.
I accidentally just opened a Lady Gaga video.
I have saved.
Oh my god.
you oh gosh sorry that was probably so loud oh my stomach
hurts imagine a horror game where you're chased by these
things you would hear it forever forever ago you would hear
it across the world it's clapping so hard it doesn't sound
like heaven is their final destination Oh, okay.
Okay, back to the tour.
We're doing a tour again, everybody.
Anyways, there's a tight-toe station there.
Again, it's just another, um...
Another, uh...
What's the word?
Arcade.
This building, I believe, is finished.
Is it not?
Am I making that up?
Maybe...
Wait.
another one no no I think this building is finished now yeah
I was finished right um yeah I remember because I went there
for a Tomie they were they did a Tomie collab and one of the
store it was like a pop-up stop so it was I I ended up not
getting anything I was so sad I forgot to go back and get
some some stuff but
yeah uh yes it's now um well the anime's here the anime I'm
pretty sure is still here I think it's just like a bunch of
random stores like there's a if I remember correctly there's
a cell phone store at the bottom and then it's like random
stuff and I think there's like a card shop in there as well
I don't quite remember exactly.
All that's in there.
But there's the animate here.
It's like these two buildings.
There are, if you go into this animate, this store has its
own elevator and this store has its own elevator.
And they do not connect.
So make sure you go in both.
They both have their own different staircases um I believe
this one on the top floor has uh this one I think this wait
is it this one that has the cafe or this one yeah it's
pretty inconvenient not gonna lie um but this one I think
has like the event stuff at the top floor here but the top
floor of this one has the yo star section and blue archive
and stuff so uh but one of them also has a cafe a small
little cafe um i say cafe it's more like snacks and drinks
and stuff um i was disappointed in the anime cafe yeah it's
not really a cafe it's like i said it's like snacks and
drinks los timbos thank you for the five gifted thank you
thank you thank you um but yeah so just be careful if you're
just like oh but i already went up all the floors but did
you go up this one as this one on the right also has more
like stuff for those interested in the BL variety and this
one is of others
let's see for those wondering Bao Bao yes this is the Misa
doll this is the the famous Wow, wow, Mr. Donuts!
So you can go here and you can sit up there and eat your
donuts.
And yeah, it's a great view because you get to see, you
know, so much of Akiva.
I mean, like the iconic stuff you can see.
Don Quixote, you can see.
Well, I don't want to sit there anymore because there's
demons afoot.
Or should I say a clap?
But yeah, there's a song.
off map here.
They have games.
They have used electronics, stuff like that.
But yeah, Misto.
Always go to Misto.
Get the pondering.
I don't remember what's here.
This is not where they're building the other APA.
That's more down there.
So I don't remember what's here.
To be honest.
I don't remember.
Um.
Another Namtara.
You have a pachinko parlor here.
And then Don Quixote, as I mentioned before.
Hold on, let's go down a little bit.
Meow, meow.
So this Don Quixote is open 24-7.
It has arcade, sixth and seventh floor.
What?
floor is is it the fifth floor the fourth or the fourth or
fifth floor has the at home but there also is the akb48 um
theater there as well don't don't don't donkey donkey hot
day donkey hot day is like a general store yeah yes it is
yes it's like um you can get clothes you can get um you can
makeup, you can get skincare, you can get costumes, you can
get...
This particular Don Quixote has a really cute Sanrio section
that I like to go check out.
This is Japanese Walmart.
Basically.
Yeah, I didn't want to say it, but yeah, basically.
But it's also this Don Quixote in particular.
I mean, any Don Quixote that you go to in like a major city,
Shibuya.
Shinjuku, Akihabara, you know like the big the big like
tourist hot spots the Don Quixote's are going to be So
crowded and again Japan loves to pack so much in a tiny
space So the aisles are very small.
There's tons of people.
It is very very very very gem packed in there So just be
aware about that, but at the bottom here they have Sorry,
they have a crape place.
They have a takoyaki place.
I don't remember what the other one is.
It's a great gift spot, though.
It is, yes.
You can get so much at Don Quixote.
It's crazy.
Yeah, yeah.
And yeah, they have a great place to get pen lights.
You can!
You can get pen lights here.
They have lots of...
You can get Yu-Os here.
Don't get me wrong.
I love Don Quixote.
I love Don Quixote so much.
I buy stuff from there all the time.
Oh yeah, there's a Tsukumo.
You have traders here.
Another place.
Buy game.
Buy.
Buy...
They have everything here, basically.
So much.
stuff here yeah yeah here you go game blu-ray dvd hobby
figurine audio iphone traders is a great place to go to yes
yes what is here i don't remember
i don't unless it wasn't done i don't remember i don't
remember sorry i should like i should do like uh um In the
past, I've made videos of me just walking through Akiba.
Like, not talking, just, like, walking down the street.
I never posted them anywhere, though.
I just always kept them for myself.
I mean, I intended on posting them.
I just never did.
Let's see.
What's some other things that I can think of?
My brain is starting to lose it.
Mother made dream in here.
There's Surugaya here.
At least one of them.
There's one Surugaya here.
There's several in Akihabara as well.
You can't see it, but there's the Akibao here.
There's a lot of like just small, what's it called?
Like figure shops and electronics stores and stuff as you
can see.
There's Carl's Jr.
There's Carl's Jr. Okay, so there's a mocha cat cat.
cafe here I have heard from friends about mocha cat cafe to
maybe don't go even it's a chain but apparently from what my
friends have told me they had an incident where they knew
that their cats were sick and they just let them continue
being sick
so uh i don't know how true that is but i you know but but
it's what my friend said i hope it's not true but i'm it has
made me wary of going to mocha now to this chain and there's
mochas in like there's one in harajuku there's one in
shinjuku there's there's it's a really popular cat cafe
chain so uh there is a cat cafe though in Akiba that I
really like.
So I will take you guys to that one.
I've never been to this meat place.
Maybe Matara would like it.
Because it's meat and wine.
There's also some other stuff like...
Oh wait.
It's more...
Wait.
There's also like an idol.
Is this where the Affiliate Saga is?
I think so.
I think this is where the Affiliate is.
and some other like idle...
Um...
What's the words?
Idle Cafes?
Yeah.
Meat wine.
Idle Carl's Jr. Exactly, exactly.
If you need the most inexpensive family restaurant in the
entire world, Caesarea is your man.
Caesarea is an Italian family restaurant.
And it is the most inexpensive restaurant you can probably
ever go to ever.
It is so...
It is so cheap.
It's actually so cheap.
If you want, like, if you were just, like, going to Japan on
a budget, Saizaria is vaguely Italian is the best way to put
it.
Yes, vaguely Italian.
Oh, um, remember how I mentioned the Nikumansi is...
opened up a new shop.
It's in here.
It's in here, so I haven't checked it out yet.
I will go next time.
I'm in Japan.
Olive Garden, too.
But seriously, the only thing is, is because it's so
inexpensive and they're open late, it's very crowded.
There's usually, like, a line.
So, especially if there's an event.
I like get you.
This is a This is an Edo Gay store that I somewhat frequent,
so if I'm brave enough, sometimes I'm a little shy and I
don't go in.
But, so if you're looking for Edo Gay, I like to go there.
anyways we're just gonna gloss over that oh there's see
another akiba oh another akiba oh you can see it better here
yeah well then no that's main dream in where maybe it's in
here or oh no just kidding that's a dentist
there's another surugaya there's just so much um let's keep
going you know what let's just keep going down the main road
until we get to until we get to the end of like the main
main main stuff and uh then i'll take you down some of the
back roads that we didn't go down before or that i like
avoided not avoided but you know what i mean um if you're a
royal host is another chain um family restaurant it's more
Food is actually so good.
It's actually so good.
If I ever go to Japan, I'm probably coming out with like
$200 of Eroge.
The great thing, too, is that you can find so much cheap
Eroge.
So $200 would be like a ton of stuff.
It would be so great.
Obsessed with Royal Hosts.
Yeah, there's also this Tendon place, which is pretty good.
Oh, wait.
The...
The pepper lunch is down here.
I'll take you there, obviously.
This is, I'm pretty sure, going to be the Apa.
Does it say?
It doesn't say yet.
But I'm almost positive this is going to be a new Apa hotel.
Which is like...
That makes it like 5 in Aki, but it's kind of crazy.
Aka is a guy!
Thank you for the vibe gifted.
Thank you.
No, right?
Another one.
It's kind of crazy.
I like this ramen here.
The Tonkotsa ramen here is pretty good.
I think this is also a chain, though.
So it's not just Akiba, but I like their stuff.
There's some more maid cafes in here.
I'm pretty sure this is also where the Lillian Plyan moved
to, which I like them.
They have two locations.
Is it here?
It might be.
I think they did move in here.
Um, uh, they're like a, they're like a cute fairy themed,
um, made cafe, very cute.
Uh, there's like a cool figure store here.
Let's see.
Miam.
Chambara!
More electronic stuff here.
Fairy themed?
Yeah!
I call this place maid cafe building because it's all maid
cafes except yaki niku like at the very bottom uh heart of
hearts used to be up here but actually now it's in um that
location where I showed with the witch's garden it actually
reopened after a little bit of what seems to be kind of
drama um but there's several maid cafes in here to get into
this to the into the maid cafes though you have to go down
here and you go down here and you enter oh you enter oh you
enter here so if you see if you're just like mind escape
that sounds like a cool cafe to go to you can't get into it
on the other way it looks shady yeah a little bit but that's
just how it is that's just how it is baby los tempos thank
you for yeah there's some maid cafes in here as well but I
have not been oh my gosh please please it's just enough
every time I have not been to these ones because not gonna
lie kind of look a little shady as well so
let's see it's a royal house oh whoa whoa whoa okay let's go
back to the main road we're in June 2021 no let's do July
2022 as recent as we can get king and queen was a good stop
for a drink I've never been this it used to be a place
called the alley which which what's the word what had bubble
tea or was it the alley I think so but they had bubble tea
which I really I would go there a couple times
Let's see,
so one of my favorite places to eat in Akiba is actually
right here.
This most burger.
Kind of similar to Fuomoko.
It has it like, you know, with the Mr. Donuts, how they like
to just eat up top with their ponder ring.
I like to come here and I like to get the Yakiniku rice bun
burger and I sit up here and I just kind of like to look at
Akiba.
maybe isn't as nice as the Mr. Donuts, but it's still
something that I do basically every time I'm in Akiva as I
go here and I sit at the, I sit at the, oh, hi people.
I sit at the little table and I like to eat the rice bun
burger because it's the best thing.
I never order anything else at Moss Burger except the rice
bun burger.
It's most delicious ever.
so it's so awesome i love i like that spot a lot um a little
more down it becomes like a little bit less you get some
gotcha stores and stuff oh right here is like a big um it
says it has like the miku racing right now um it's for a
while it's been like kind of a good smile store not good But
is it Good Smile?
It has, it has like Racing Miku and they have like some
other figures.
And, um.
Uh.
That's Good Smile HQ?
No way!
What?
But it's still here.
It's still here.
It's, um, it's just like they have the, it's the, this looks
like it's just a Racing Miku like pop-up.
But they do still have Racing Miku stuff inside.
They just have other figures as well.
um like they have like some pop-up parade things and they
have uh just a this just like some general figure stuff
there used to be a scam postcard store right around here
what this one this one with the lady that always tries to
get you to go in uh this chat time is not here anymore which
makes me so sad it was a bubble tea place
It's funny because in the game Akiba's trip you like fight
these ladies.
You fight these ladies because they're always so pushy about
getting you to buy the art.
So annoying.
Down here is another...
Oh, wait, what?
Okay, 2019.
I was going to say this is...
I think it's this building or this building.
One of these buildings is another made...
Oh, made cafe building.
Okay, let's see.
This one.
I was close.
This is another, like, very made cafe.
There's a bunch of different themes here.
One of them is a V-Tuber.
I think it's this one.
It's the V-Tuber themed cafe.
I still haven't gone because I'm very...
Someone once said that it was weird when they went.
So I'm still deciding.
Is that Picardine?
that might be Picardy but yeah there's lots of made cafes
and themed cafes I mean this one's a cheerleading themed one
not necessarily a made cafe how weird I don't know I'm gonna
go next time I'm gonna go next time I'm gonna get over my
fears of the weird cafe I won't tell them I'm a YouTuber oh
yeah see you can kind of see it's closed off but it is it is
like open all the time now it used to always be like from
every time i saw it was like a miku a miku uh miku like
exhibition type thing great tour have you watched akiba made
war hi sketch thank you i'm actually in the middle of
watching it i watched an episode right before the stream i
don't remember what episode i'm on though i'm on episode
like five I think.
If you're into Hello Project, there's the big Hello Project
store here.
There's also some other hobby stores up in here.
An army store.
This hobby shop that has a bunch of military stuff.
I've only been once.
But yeah.
The quote unquote main Akiba stuff really kind of ends here.
there's also a bunch of see how see Chuo Dori Avenue so Chuo
Dori is this main street here um there's some other stuff I
want to show some like little things like off the beaten
path if you come down this way you can I always I always use
Tam Tam as like my as my marker it's like my That's my big
marker here.
Yep.
Let's see.
Um, this way.
Oh, here.
So this is a, this is a cafe called Fruits de Sezon, I
think.
Does it say?
Furu Fudu Sezon is what is what's covered up Furu Fudu Sezon
And basically it's the most delicious They're so awesome
They're so delicious They are um So as the title implies The
fruits change each season So they uh They um only have
whatever Whatever fruit is in, oh, oh, we're back!
Oh, oh, oh, hello.
Moshi moshi.
Just refresh.
They got her.
We're back?
Okay, sorry.
Sorry about that.
So this is Furu Fudu Seizom.
And like I said, as the title implies, they serve part of
the based on what fruit is in season so um so you'll only
get stuff that is of that season and like the menu is very
like it changes all the time it's so good it's so good i
don't know why it's called frouf but it says fruits parfait
that word does that say pot that's potte potty i don't know
but um i i highly recommend this place it's really really
delicious it's so good frouf do season but also here is a
place that i love to go to all the time oh my gosh it's
called blend dream candy and if you love or sorry blend
dream park um if you like if you like dojin artists i love
their apple pie yeah i'll have to try it next time by shamin
if you like dojin artists and stuff this is a this is a
store of just like gachapon and um tapestries and It's
mostly gacha porn, I'll be honest.
But they have like vending machines of art, of like
tapestries and various goods of different artists like
Shiratama Sensei and Pan No Mimi and Kantoku and...
Very adorable, very humorous.
Humorous?
It was so funny.
what's so funny but uh yeah um I I like this place I like to
come here and get their gacha pong um but if you're
wondering where is this like what this is like the most
random side street ever if you go down this street all the
way which I'm going to show you which actually it's kind of
fun it's kind of fun right here is the fire department you
can see their own little anime mascot.
The fire department has their own anime mascot.
Sorry,
I'm skipping a bunch of places, but trying to show as much
as possible.
Look at that!
We're back at the station!
There's Tamashi Nations.
There's the station.
There's a UDX.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah.
So it's just a little bit of a walk from there.
Damn dragon, thank you for the 10 gifted.
Yeah, we went in a full circle.
I'm actually going to go back down this way too.
Because there was something else I wanted to show.
Um...
More, more, more.
Did you know you can walk inside M's on Google Maps?
Wait, I tried!
I tried.
How do you do it?
How do you do?
Fellow kids.
Cute.
Oh my gosh, Ami!
Thank you for the raid, Ami!
Thank you!
Froggers!
Hello everybody!
I'm doing a tour of Akihabara, my favorite place ever.
I've kind of shown a lot of stuff already, but...
But, uh...
Um...
Yeah, welcome david thank you for the gifted murphy thank
you for the five gifted ray mac thank you for the five
gifted thank you guys 10 000 thank you for the five gifted
thank you thank you thank you spank thank you for the 20
thank you thank you thank you thank you ducky thank you for
the gifted thank you guys um let me see i actually am so
curious if this is here i'm so curious well first off um
actually where okay hold on i'm gonna be checking sideways
every so up it's that wait can i go in there this for um if
you guys uh follow ayami sensei this is where she had her um
collaboration cafe with asan cafe so it was here but it's
this no wait you can see him oh my gosh oh my gosh okay do
you guys want to see the scariest thing?
Hold on, I have to, I have to send it to my, oops, that's
TikTok, don't listen, I have to send it to myself.
You can see his reflection.
Okay, so imagine, hold on, I have to find the picture
actually.
Imagine you're walking down the street at night in
Akihabara.
Um, actually, I walked this way because I walked this way.
No, I walked this way I, um, some, I had some friends that
were staying down the street, and so I was going to meet
them, and it was dark, it was night time, it was, you know,
it was quite, I don't want to say it was quite late, but it
was, you know, it was, the sun had set.
Where is this picture?
Can you guys tell what it is from, from the reflection?
too so um i just want to let you know that where is this
picture hold on i'm gonna find it i'm so sorry i should have
had this prepared but i actually didn't even know if he was
gonna be there
mothra a clown close maybe a bird man flamingo why do you
why flamingo Where is this picture?
Oh, wait.
I think I'm close.
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
Let me pull it up.
Wait.
One second.
Sorry.
Um.
One second.
Oh, I didn't want it to accidentally open the pictures in
the wrong browser, which is why I hit it.
Sorry.
One second.
Uh, and also let me check for reflection.
So.
You're walking down the street.
And you see him.
Oh.
It's dark and you lost your way.
You don't know where you're going.
But you hear a rustle behind in a dark alleyway.
You turn confused.
And who else could it be?
Actual cannibal.
Olaf from Frozen.
Do you see it now?
Do you see it now with the reflection and then the picture?
This is what I saw walking home at night.
It scared the actual crap out of me.
I was like, oh my god!
I don't know why he's there.
Actual cannibal, Olaf from Frozen, is real.
And he exists in this building.
Yoro Zuya 7 BIRU.
Across from Asan Cafe.
And clearly, this is from July 22.
2022.
so, so,
so, whoa, my phone just fell, sorry.
Um, so he's been there for several years now.
Um, so, So you can probably go to this place and visit scary
Olaf.
Again, he's across from Cafe Asan.
This is a real mystery.
Have you ever seen this?
Bajamin.
I know Olaf.
Why?
Olaf is.
Anyway, I just wanted to share the Blendream and the
cafe-a-san.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Let me out!
I have it.
Last year, since last year.
This is June.
And he's holding like a...
He's holding a...
Oh my gosh, I think...
Oh, there we go.
He's holding a candy bucket, like a Halloween bucket.
So I thought he was like a Halloween...
Like prop, but no.
I don't know.
That Olaf is so terrifying.
It's so scary.
It's so funny to see.
Oh, I like this hotel here.
This hotel...
on oh here you can see the name the dormy in akihabara i
really like because at the top right up here is um is an
onsen it's an outdoor onsen it's not very big but it's um
dormy and goaded yeah it's really nice so um it's also uh
the rooms are like kind of more japanese style like they
have the tatami mats and everything like that.
But, um, Dormian rocks.
Yeah!
Um, but, uh, and it's quite affordable.
It's, I think it still counts as a, um, as a business hotel,
so it's quite affordable, and, um, and you can, you can use
the onsen for free.
Do you like the idol masterment?
Yeah, I do.
Didn't know there was an onsen in Akiba.
It's like...
Onsen, maybe in quotes, but it's still really nice.
I stayed at the Dormy Inn across from Tokyo Dome last month.
It was amazing.
Oh, nice.
Yes, also I should mention, it is a chain.
So, um, so, uh, it's not like you have to stay only at this
one.
There are Dormy Inns at other places, and I believe they all
have the onsen at the top, so it's pretty nice.
realize we're back to Chuodori but you might also notice
there is a train station here this is for the metro which um
you saw there was the metro for Akihabara station oh there's
pepper lunch but the metro for Akihabara station is the
Hibiya line this is actually um we hold on I'm trying to get
the name so you can see it.
Uh.
So now, should I say it?
There we go.
So Sui Hirocho.
So, if you are coming to Akihabara and you're just like, oh,
my hotel is not is not, it does not go directly to Akiba,
you could also check to see if it goes to Sui Hirocho
because this will also lead you exactly on Chuo Dori, on the
main street.
So it's not like Akiba station proper, but it is still in
the heart of Akihabara.
And then there's, you know, the exit here.
Or exit entrance here.
Exit entrance over there.
Yes, the Giza line.
You can see, you can see it's the orange one right there.
There is, there are a couple other train stations you can
take.
What was one?
Hold on, let me check.
I can't remember the name.
Hold on, I'm going to check from maps.
There's another one that takes you, it's a little bit more
of a walk, but by a walk, I mean like two minutes.
It's not even that long.
directions to Akihabara
the other station is wait here we go train station is Ogawa
Machi Ogawa Machi oh there is also Okachi Machi yeah but
Ogawa Machi takes you takes you it's like I would have to go
kind of far it's kind of all the way it's kind of all the
way like down there by Akiba Station but it drops you off
like maybe like a three minute walk to to like Pasela area
so if you're like trying to get to Akihabra I would
definitely look at some stations around as well because Not
all of them are going to lead to Akihabara station proper,
but you could maybe find, I mean, Google Maps will do that
for you, right?
Like, Google Maps will find you the best way to get there,
but, um, you know, you don't have to go to...
Whoa!
Where are we here?
You don't have to go to Akihabara station proper.
There's a couple others around, too.
Wow, Japan has CBD.
I know, right?
It's so weird to see now.
It's really weird to see.
I'm trying to get in here.
So, if we're going to go down some of the back streets now.
Back streets.
There's Culture Zone.
So, um, Akiva, like, seems huge and small all at the same
time.
It's so big and small all at the same time.
Where?
Um...
Dolphin.
I can't tell.
Where am I?
I know where I am, but like, I'm trying to figure out.
Okay, hold on.
For some reason, I always...
If I'm looking this way, it's more confusing than if I'm
looking this way.
I don't know why.
Bunny Garden!
Yes!
Okay.
Yes, this is...
Yes!
Okay, that's why I kept turning around.
This is the bunny garden street!
Right here!
This is the bunny garden street right here.
And so...
not here this this is where the chubby girl mid cafe is what
says July homemade cafe and dining honey honey I've never
been here before but this is where it's at in case you are
trying to find it Changrida is here you're welcome you're
welcome everybody who's been like where is it where is it
yeah i was like i i thought it was either this street or
this one street over but i was like no i'm pretty sure it's
this one of course there's the hard off and the hobby off
there's some kebabs there's kebabs um there's always the
star kebabs which is like the more They closed down for a
while and then they opened back up.
Which is right.
Oh, I mentioned, wait, no, it's the other street.
Oh, there it is.
No, that's not Starkabob.
Where is Starkab?
Where the hell am I?
Oh, that's the park.
It's this way.
Sorry guys, I'm starting to get sleepy.
there's star kebab there's star kebab a culture zone is way
farther than it looks but you can always see it like it
looks so far but it's actually like a good landmark you know
what i mean this is where this is another place that i the
other jambara there's like another retro um retro game place
down here in the basement someone asked other than like
super potato oh sorry um there's here as well yes yes yes
yes um stark kebab but i know this street i know this street
the bestest and i'll show you why in like two seconds
because this place i go this street i visit all the time!
Here is Akihabara Dear Stage!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Did Mint mention Atoreya Akiba Station?
I did, I did.
Here's Akihabara Dear Stage, my beloved Dear Stage.
Every time I come to Akihabara, I go here, place!
My lovely Dear Stage.
arcana project you have eyes avarisa you have oh mia regina
rest in peace wait this is from 2022 can i see is there a
more latest one there is not that's okay they always
advertise like recent releases for their talent um on these
little billboards here so if you don't know dear stage um it
is a it is a legendary spot of akihabara It is...
Oh yeah, let's go back in time and see.
Oh my gosh, wait.
If I go back to like 2016, it'll be Dempa, won't it?
Ah!
Oh, wait, how did I...
Hold on.
Wait, I went to March.
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
Dempa Gumi Inc.
DSDJ, Yokozo!
And then this is another Dempa Gumi album.
And then this is Moso Calibration.
One Man Live Yeah, oh my gosh Natskashi Natskashi It's
always been the same Thomas Thanks for the 10 gift Thank you
So I've I've talked about it before But on the first floor
here There's a big stage right here You can go in If the
curtain, sometimes the curtain is closed, just walk right
past it.
You can open up the curtain.
They just do it for like live performances and stuff like
that.
If there's gonna be a, if there's gonna be a live
performance, you just go on in.
As long as it's not a ticketed day, of course.
But they'll stop you, of course, if there's, if it is.
And then this floor is the cafe, and then this floor is the
bar.
So the whole building is Deer Stage.
Are they open every day?
No.
No, they're not.
I don't remember what day they're closed, though.
How do you get tickets for Deer Stage?
That's the cool thing.
Unless it's an event, the tickets might be a little more
hard to get because sometimes they're fan club related and
things like that.
But for normal days, you just walk in and you pay.
And that's it.
It's super easy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wonder...
What?
2009.
Okay, so it's hard to tell, but this is actually, like, they
lift up.
Like, they're, they're, they're, it's like a sliding door,
basically.
Oh, my gosh.
Is that lettuce?
Oh, my God.
Stop.
Oh.
Are Nora and Petra in this?
I can't, I don't think so.
Wait, is Amane in this?
I can't tell.
There's, there's meeting up front that looks like...
Nemo, Ita-so!
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, I'm fangirling a little bit.
This is, oh wait.
This would be past, this is, would be past Nora, Petra, I'm
pretty sure.
And then, Moso Calibration again.
Rest in peace.
lift up actually so you can actually see here oh my gosh wow
oh my gosh they don't lift it anymore obviously but wow oh
my god old old dear stage old akihabara but it also also
still kind of looks the same doesn't it let's see from 2009
to 2022 This is just a computer store instead of what was
also a computer store.
So, not so much has changed.
Gotten a little wider.
It's a blue computer store instead of red.
Yeah.
So, you know, it is kind of, it is a little comforting,
right, because, you know, so much of Akiba has changed, but
it is really comforting to know that also so much has stayed
the same.
This is Akiba, or Akiba, this is Dear Stages official
vocaloid even too, To ne Leon who is drawn by Poyoyon, one
of my favorite artists ever, who also known as Akio
Watanabe, also known as the Bakemonogatari artist, who is
also voiced by my kami-oshi Yumumi Nebu!
Yes, he also did the art for Kersaya, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
isn't Nemu also a vocaloid you are right she is also her own
vocaloid that she also goes by you memme Nemu she's very
cute yeah and they built this family mart a couple years ago
so if you are ever at deer stage and you're just like I'm
just here for the live performances I don't really want to
go to the cafe which you should go to the cafe but it's only
a thousand yen to see the shows and you get three a night
usually um but if you're like i'm gonna go eat you can leave
and then go to family mart and then go back
yeah um what else there's so much i'm gonna probably rush a
little bit more through some of these because I I was dying
to get so sleepy oh whoa yeah this is all built here but I
don't remember what it is oh this ramen place is good I'm
almost positive I mentioned it before in my previous ones
but this is a this is a chicken ramen so their broth is
chicken based so some people can't have pork right so if
you're ever like I want chicken ramen um or i can't have
pork then this place has really really good chicken broth
ramen but also if you're just like oh i'm vegetarian i can't
have chicken broth either well they also have a vegetarian
ramen so um so uh you can also get full vegetarian ramen at
this chicken noodle location.
It's good though.
Yeah, it's good, it's good, it's good.
It's good.
Oh yeah, here my friends and I lovingly call this the deer
stage APA because it's right next to deer stage.
We're just like, go to deer stage, go to APA, go back home.
So there's one of the other APAs in Akihabara.
Oh my gosh, I feel like There's another Akibao.
I feel like I'm going to have to do another part.
I feel like I'm...
I'm...
Living the life.
For those...
Some people mentioned it before.
Here is your Mandarake.
This entire building.
You do the selling stuff here at the bottom.
And then every floor above is this whole building is
Mandarake.
Um, not a mandrake.
I mean, yes, mandrake.
A part two would be cool.
Maybe if I do a part two, I can do some actual footage that
I take.
I will do my best.
What's your favorite place in the downtown?
The downtown?
Downtown.
When you're slow and you want to.
go you know you can go downtown i like to go to the parlor
show at the deer stage downtown yeah food recommendations
too i would actually not gonna lie bashamine has been in the
chat bashamine has so many great akihabara food
recommendations so definitely check out her for her video,
her tours of Akiba as well.
And I think for me, I probably give more of a perspective
from a, you know, like a tourist.
So, but she has some really great food recommendations.
So, I'm pitching her.
Yeah, yeah.
She and I have collabed a long time ago in the past.
She's always been so cute.
Bashamine!
Everybody go follow.
But yeah, here's Mandarake.
Again, you take the stairs.
There's also like a teeny tiny elevator here.
If you don't want to take the stairs like up eight floors.
But the inside is also very tiny and packed.
So just be mindful.
There's a ramen place here, which has really huge ramen.
anime shows as well.
Let's see.
Hard off here as well.
I remember this spot very vividly because I was standing
like maybe maybe right here or right here.
Also, I love this.
I love how they're just like Hey check out what maids we've
got For at home Maid Cafe That's so funny
Yeah Oh thank you Ghostor Thank you Thank you Thank you But
I was standing right here.
I remember this spot so vividly because I was waiting on a
friend and this guy came up.
And he tried talking to me in English.
He was just like, are you lost?
You look so lost.
I was just standing here on my phone, like waiting for my
friend.
I was like, no, I'm not lost.
I'm waiting for a friend.
They'll be here soon.
And he was just like, no, you are lost.
You are looking at your phone.
You don't know where to go.
I was like, no, no, no, no, I'm just, I'm just, I'm just
waiting, I'm just waiting for my friend, they'll be here,
and they're like, I don't believe you, I don't believe that
you're waiting for your friend, here, here, here, come with
me, come with me, and I'm like, they tried, like, they tried
kidnapping me, and I had to be like, I'm waiting, for my
friend!
I had to be so insistent and then I had to be like oh like I
had to be like my friend is my friend is down here so I just
I just walked I just it was so weird it was such a weird
experience I was like why are you why would you think I'm
lost looking at my phone but then again I've also seen some
people in Akiba some foreigners looking at their phones and
I'm like they cloths.
So, maybe...
Maybe I just had a silly look about me.
Here is Sudugaya.
Another Sudugaya if you're looking for...
Oh, Kandu.
Is it still here?
This Kandu.
It's another hundred yen store.
But I prefer three coin.
Oh, here's the other side of the Apla.
You are lost is crazy work.
Right?
It's so funny.
Yeah, there's so many, like, look at this.
Look at how, look at this.
I'll be honest, I buy all my stuff from Sudugaya Online.
This sounded like I just said Gaia Online.
Sudugaya Online.
So I don't really visit the stores that much themselves, but
yeah.
Let's wait.
I was like, is this the kindergarten?
So there's like a random park and kindergarten here.
It's pretty funny.
I'm trying to look for another place.
It's not bee cat, though.
Trying to look for the other Annie Song bar that my friend
suggested.
Yeah.
Yeah, here's a kindergarten.
It's kind of cute because around 5 p.m.
It is 5 p.m., right?
At 5 p.m., the chimes will go off.
So, um...
You can, uh...
You'll hear that.
Okay, hold on.
I want to go back.
Not quite done.
Hold on.
I asked my Normie friends to pick up an animator book from
Mandarake while they were in Akiba, and they were led to the
floor with all the dojans.
I mean, there are a lot of floors with dojans.
um this is i mentioned it earlier uh lily and pleon this is
the other location um i think it's this floor and this floor
um but they're very cute this floor has like the entrance
and uh some other stuff i wish these were open in the um
it's so frustrating but they're not open um there's a
restaurant in here pizza i'm pretty sure Okay, go back down
here.
Oh, wait.
Mades!
Spotted.
Look how cute they are.
Also, in Akiba, please don't take pictures of the maids.
Some of them wear signs that, like, say don't take pictures.
But you're not supposed to.
Be respectful.
Don't be those tourists, you know.
Because now...
I don't know.
I'm so worried about some places.
Because...
Like you heard about how like tourists are banned from
certain places in Kyoto now.
Because of how they're chasing after the Michael and
everything.
The geisha.
Yeah.
Yeah and Gion.
it's kind of crazy the that the geisha chasers and guion
yeah they're banned from like certain streets so just be
respectful you know there's there's what it's like one thing
to be like yeah I'm I'm having I'm you know I'm a foreigner
I don't really know what I'm doing I'm having fun I'm trying
to be respectful you know and there's just just being like,
you know, rowdy rude, you know.
So.
Down here.
I like this poster because Idol Content Expo is drawn by an
idol I really like.
She's in Debba Gumi Inc.
Her name is Perorin.
And she drew this.
She's so cute.
Okay.
I think the last time I did my Akiba tour, we were like,
Akiba CIA, baby.
We're going to go to Spy Bar.
akiba cia i regret to inform you that akiba cia is no longer
in fact well i was gonna say i think it's been replaced by a
dog thing but the dog thing is right here but yeah actually
it's um what is it it's it's another like maid cafe type
thing it's i think it's like some moon themed maid cafe or
concept cafe whichever so there is no more spy bar Akiba CIA
I'm the Akiba Chiyoda intelligence agency I'm so I never got
the cow
I'll regret it for the rest of my afterlife I will I will
now it's Akiba Iris moon themed what does that mean It's
like, um, like, I don't, I think I took a picture of it.
Hold on, let me see if I can find it real quick.
Um, because I remember taking a picture and being like, Oh
my god, no, Akiba CIA.
Akiba CIA is gone.
Oh, I don't know when I took a picture of it, though.
It could have been any time.
It could have been.
I could have been on my old phone even.
I don't know.
Hold on.
I'll do a brief lookover.
Not here.
Is that it?
No, that's Umumosemir.
I don't want to take too much time I'm not looking for it,
you know.
That's a comiquette.
I don't know.
Let me see if maybe we can time travel too.
Nope.
Yeah, but it's like a different concept cafe now.
So sad.
So, so sad.
But what's not sad is if you're looking for...
Wow, thank you!
I have expected to see you on the street view of Deer State.
Why?
I don't just stand out there all the time.
Oh, wait.
I think I'm reading the wrong one.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you for the tour of Akiba.
It was so cool seeing all the places.
I'm planning on visiting sometime next year, so I'll be sure
to check out your recommendations.
Yeah, of course.
Thank you.
If we didn't want to hear you fangirling, we wouldn't tune
in to watch you talk about your holy land.
Yeah.
A theater, a live theater.
So there's Twin Box Garage, which, to be honest, I've never
been to this.
Oh, wait, this is now an e-sports.
Oh, wait, they changed it.
So it's only this theater right in here.
Oh, this used to be a thing up here, too.
Okay, never mind.
But yeah, Twin Box Garage is a live house where you can
watch idols.
And sometimes even...
You'll see idols outside the station at, like outside
Akihabara station, and they'll be passing out flyers.
And this actually happened to me once where I saw some idols
and I was like, you know what, I'm gonna, I'm never seen
them before.
I'm gonna go out of my comfort zone a little bit.
And so I, um, I asked them like who were they were and they
told me who they were and they were like, yeah, actually
once, um, once a month we do a free show at Akihabara Twin
Box.
and we're doing one tonight so if you come you can see our
free show and i was like what that's so awesome is there a
show every night not every night no it's not like a
dedicated place like deer stage um it's more like specific
events like you know sometimes there's like idol shows
though where it's like a bunch of idol groups it's called a
taiban for those shows where like you know 15 groups will be
performing but um but yeah I went and I saw them and I was
there with like five other people and everyone was staring
at the ghost girl who's who clearly was out of place but um
it was fun it was a lot of fun uh so hello welcome to
membership thank you I found a bunch of great idol groups
doing that too yeah So if you ever want to experience like a
true Akiba idol show, Twin Box is a super awesome place to
go to.
There's also over here, Akibao, another one.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
But I'm also going to introduce one of my favorite made
cafes in Akihabara, right here.
Jam Akihabara.
So when you say the Akibao, when you say the Twin Box,
you're right here.
It's very easy to see because of all the because of all the
what's it called?
The landmarks.
I've mentioned Jam before but Jam Akihabara is again kind of
like Kiramate Cafe where it's not your clap me, me, mu, ma,
ma, ma, ma.
Please, my drama.
It's like Kiramat get Kiramat Kir mid cafe where i'm going
mad that's for sure um where it's not like your super high
energy like woohoo this is a mid cafe moi moi cune um it's
very like chill the girls are like they they kind of give
you give you your food and leave you alone lots of people
come here to like with their their computers to like work on
stuff it just feels like it's a cafe with maids essentially
and so um they do also a lot of collabs with like with
visual novels they've done collabs with vtubers so sometimes
they have special menus they have special menus where it's
like specially made cocktails by the maids um they have
seasonal stuff like they just have a lot and it's so chill
it's like the perfect place to just kind of go and wind down
so after a busy day i'm almost always at gem akihabara if
i'm not at deer stage so a normal cafe but you get to see
maids walking around exactly what's the name of the cafe
again jam akihabara right here you can see it j-a-m so yeah
it's super duper nice like if you're not wanting the like
everything like that everything it's just like it's so chill
it's so nice it's so nice What is this?
I keep seeing this.
Oh, Akikaru?
Akikaru is a, um...
It looks... Is this...
Thank you.
Um, Akikaru is a, uh...
Is a, um...
Is a...
Magazine.
It's a free magazine.
Oh, it's redo of healer!
Oh my god, that's so funny.
Um...
Oh yeah, you're right!
I love jam.
Me too!
But Akikaru is a free magazine that you'll see across in
certain places in Akihabara where they show...
It's just like an Akiba-themed magazine.
They're free.
You can take them for free.
They have like Akikaru models and stuff.
And sometimes they do interviews with them or they show off
new ads.
anime or new places in Akiba.
So, um, yeah.
Uh.
That's not redo.
That's the animal slave girl one.
Oh, it's not.
Oh, wait.
I thought, okay.
It's so hard to read backwards.
I thought it said healer.
Ha-rem.
I have no idea.
I'm trusting whatever you guys say.
I don't know this one.
I don't know if it's even still there.
Maid Cafe sometimes come and go so quickly.
Which is a little sad.
Because if you find one that you really like.
But Jam has been there forever.
Like a really long time.
Really, really long time.
Um, here's a...
So if you're confused.
are here's culture zone um this is the big big building
there's title over there meat mop and uh this is uh the loss
the the used to be dragon quest lawson and this is a maid
cafe building um meat mop there's always girls here
advertising this place but i've never been it says it's a
mate cafe con cafe and it says for 13 hours it's 2,000 yen
nomi hodai which is all you can drink which I'm like huh
huh huh
but there's always girls advertising it right here they're
always standing here with a big sign and stuff another
akibao welcome many thanks zero
Let's see, um, so if you're, again, if you're all turned
around, if you go down this way, you'll get to UDX and
you'll get to, um, the train station.
If you go down this way, which we are going to go down,
you'll get to Akiba Zetai Dyo-Iki.
I mean, you can drink water.
So true.
The no mi hoda is the water.
There's some other maid cafes in here.
Wait.
Wait, in here too?
Oh, no, here, here, sorry.
There's some other maid cafes in here.
There's like a...
I think this is the Danso.
Not Danso.
I think this is...
It might be Danso.
It might be Danso or it's Ikemen.
I can't remember.
there's an OL cafe down here as well so this is kind of like
the off the beaten path a little bit can I go please there
we go the back roads I'm so impressed by how much you know
about Akiba so cute stop it Maya stop it there's several
places back here that I want to mention though because
they're really cool IMHO why is everything closed I can't
tell where the...
Oh no, you guys, I can't...
Everything is blocked by the cars.
I can't tell where anything is.
Um...
I can't tell you guys where the OL Cafe is.
I think it's somewhere back there.
I think I passed it, but I couldn't see it.
Oh, time travel.
Yeah, we will in a second.
But before we time travel, I kind of mentioned cat cafes
before.
This one, I like this cat cafe.
It's called Neco Jalala.
and um it's it's pretty small but it's very cute the cats
are um i don't know i find it better than like the really
big open cat cafes because um obviously you get more people
in there so the cats are a little more tired in the big cat
cafes and um also because they're bigger there's less chance
of seeing a cat but here the cats are like everywhere
they're like all over the place they're up everywhere so I
recommend Neko Jalala if you want to go to a cat cafe in
Akihabara I have not heard anything bad about them so I hope
I hope it's okay and sometimes when you're walking by you
can see a cat in the window as well but it has a sign here
it says don't don't tap on the glass Don't hurt the cat.
Continuing onward.
More concept cafe?
Made cafe?
Perhaps.
I'm really...
Okay guys, I will...
Oh yeah, we'll travel back in time to see if we can find the
OL cafe too.
Sorry, I forgot about it a little bit.
Because I got distracted by this.
Ta-da!
Hold on.
You can see the posters from here.
This is a place called Milish, which is another maid cafe.
Sorry, I only know maid cafes.
But Milish is special because this is the maid cafe featured
in Sinesgate.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is the Sinesgate Cafe.
Actually, I think it's this seat or this seat right here is
where they sit.
sat in the in the show and there's even pictures of them
sitting in those seats at the tables it's so so cute very
sunyang yeah it's it's one of these it's one of these seats
so um yeah you can go here um it's again it's a little more
made cafe than it's like in the middle between like cure and
jam and like made dreaming and at home it's like just in
that middle where they still do a little bit of like maid
cafe fan service but they don't perform here it's like a
little chill but of course you have to go if you're a fan of
fan of Steinsgate they have like Steinsgate gotcha pon in
there and this is such a good beginners maid cafe yeah that
is a that is a good way to put it have you been to Akiba
Guild at all I have not because to be honest i don't care so
much about i mean i i was worried that it was more bar than
cafe you know because i was like there's like the whole
casino aspect and everything my buddy from kfp went there oh
nice what do you mean beginner um beginner in that like a
maid cafe like made dreaming or at home or some of the other
ones might be a little overwhelming in terms of how the
energy is but this one's a little more chill if you want to
see if you just kind of enjoy the made cafe vibe you know
it's not too weird or overwhelming yeah yeah exactly it's
pretty chill i'll be cringe and go as okabe and cosplay it's
not cringe at all in fact i'm sure people have done it
before yeah
I started with made dreaming.
That's okay too.
It's not bad.
Um, it's not bad at all to start with made dreaming.
But if you're looking, if you're just like trying to ease
someone into the made cafe world, you know, this is a good
one, probably.
Um, is there a Metal Gear made cafe?
Did you know there was a Metal Gear cafe in France?
Did you know that that existed?
In France?
Why?
It was like a pop-up cafe.
I'm pretty sure it was France.
Yeah.
I think it was for MGS 4.
No, 4 or 5.
Yeah.
It was somewhere in Europe.
It might have not been France, but...
Yeah.
It was a special event.
No, it's not there anymore It was just a pop-up I'm so
depressed But also, I would have had to go to France
This place right next to it also Right next to Mylish It is
still here, right?
It might be here Or it might be down here Thank you Thank
you I like how when you're the tour guide Akiba appears to
be Oops, I made Hey, can you I've talked about figure stores
too I talked about those annoying clappers at Taito Genie
store Welcome to membership, thank you Thank you, thank you
Made dreaming Anil has English menu software on their stuff
Oh yes, made dreaming and at home also are very foreigner
friendly because they're like the two biggest in Akiba so
they have a lot of good they have a lot of um not only just
usually maids at least some maids that speak a little bit of
english um but they also have english menu so but anyway um
this place is called place is called off kai um and it says
menu list but it's not the type of menu that you'd expect
it's not a restaurant this is actually a hair salon which is
so cool it's a otaku themed hair salon where if you're just
like i want to get my hair cut like i don't know kirito you
can go and request your hair to be cut like an anime
character you can tell them an anime character and be like i
want i want rem blue hair color and they'll make it happen
can i get a goku cut
get the you oh my gosh Yugi that'd be crazy but yeah so they
kind of specialize in that um and like on the inside you
can't see it wait let me see if I can uh no it's still
covered oh yeah you can see here like there's all this manga
and everything on the walls oh yeah you can see here the cut
the color the head spa the treatment yeah hi my lash oh I
don't think this hottomoto is here anymore yeah
but um whoo those prices I'm gonna be honest these prices
are extremely actually these are on the better side of Japan
not gonna lie uh this is from 2021 so I don't know if it's
any different but this is really normal for hair salon in
japan unless it's like there's there are some cheaper ones
there was one that's chain i don't remember it but um yeah 5
000 yen for a haircut look you're getting the goku you're
getting the goku what do you expect
sorry i'm finishing my drink i got some tai tea earlier But
yeah.
So if you're wondering where the heck are we?
If you go down here, oh I'm gonna go back to 2023 because
things have changed.
If you go down here, if you're here, you're just like where
the heck are we?
I'll show you.
Please, please, take bigger steps please.
Take bigger steps please.
You can kind of read it.
It's the Tam Tam that we were at before.
Gap Tracks.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Can I have a Saitama haircut too?
Yeah, you can.
Traffic is bad.
We're back at the Tam Tam.
So right there is Sui Hiroashi.
And this is all Chuo Dori.
And then down here.
Oh no, sorry.
Wrong street.
This is Culture Zone.
Down here is Culture Zone.
And this is Chubby Maid Cafe.
This is Old Lady.
old lady the the old lady Sasquatch of Akihabara
what's the idol landscape like now compared to say 10 to 15
years ago do current idols look at 48 slash hello project
golden era as a big deal or is that now considered boomer
tier thanks for the tour thanks for the question i i think
now it is kind of boomer territory there's like a bunch of
groups and heroines that of the up-and-coming stuff.
Groups that are, idols that are big on TikTok are kind of
what's like taking over because a lot of girls have been
getting more into idols.
Especially like there's a group called I Life that's really
popular.
They're part of heroines.
But I would say that, yeah, and also K-pop has influenced
stuff a ton.
So, yeah, Fruit Zipper, Fruit Zipper is really big right
now.
It is kind of like, not to say that there's not people that
still admire Hello Project, because Hello Project is still a
group, and of course, AKB is still a group and everything,
but, um, yeah.
The whole wave of Chica idols that take after Omori Seiko
are fun.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So, I don't know.
It's hard to say.
Times just grow and change.
That's all.
Exactly, exactly.
When I was in Japan last, I went to Tower Records.
And as I was walking in, there was a big group of people.
And I was like, whoa, what's going on?
And there was AKB signing a...
A big, a poster in the front of the store.
And I thought to myself, I was like, if I, if this had been
me, like, if this had been me 10 years ago, I would have
probably, I would have auto-conned it all over the floor.
I would have auto-conned all over the floor.
I would have been like, like, I just would have lost my
mind.
But, um, yeah.
But I kind of was just like, oh, that's neat.
And then I went on my way.
Not a fan of that verb.
Don't say it like that.
But you know what I mean.
Yeah.
Uh.
Anyway.
Well.
I've skipped over a bunch of stuff.
But I think this might be a good place to...
call it um oh wait we were gonna go back in time for the uh
for the um the ol cafe maybe i've been actually quite tired
because um okay guys announcement actually some of you
already know this but that's okay if you are on the patreon
I got a second cat!
I thought Otakon meant the other thing he's known for doing.
Hmm?
What's that?
Wait, actually, wait, what do you mean?
Thank you, man.
No, thank you!
Yeah, I got another cat!
She's so cute.
I hadn't announced it sooner because I was, like, kind of
wanting to see how...
how um how uh butaro reacted to her um but uh they're
getting along ish they're only hissing sometimes um but i
didn't want to say it sooner because i was like what if she
what if she doesn't get along with my cat and um then i have
to like you know what if it's like really bad to The point.
Mintu already told us?
Not on stream.
Wait, I told you guys yesterday?
I did?
I told you yesterday?
You said you didn't want to say it, but you did.
Okay.
Well, okay.
Let me explain why I've been so tired then.
because do you know how exhausting it's been like taking
care of like two babies where like i have to keep one cat in
a separate room and then another cat and i let them go and i
let them and i do stuff with them and then also trying to
get them to like each other and i'm pretty tired okay i'm
gonna take tomorrow well i'm not taking tomorrow off because
i'm actually quite busy tomorrow but is the new cat just a
kitten she's about one years old so she's pretty kitten
i'm so sorry when did i say that i told you guys when did i
say
a singular years old kind of past the kitten age yes but
Last night?
Yeah, but like when last night?
Gosh, I don't remember at all.
No, I know I did Bunny Garden yesterday, but I don't
remember when I said it last night.
Someone asked about it.
Oh, and I was...
That's probably why I don't remember because I...
Because I...
Because I was thinking of...
You know, because it was brought up as a super chat.
Okay, I remember.
Okay, I remember now!
I remember now, I remember now.
Yeah, I said the new one wasn't Sinky.
I remember, I remember, I remember.
I also have to remember that with Bunny Garden, my brain was
entirely on the assets.
I remember, I remember.
Or, I mean, wasn't yesterday Majong?
Yeah, it was Majong.
Now I'm confused.
You guys are older than I am.
You guys said Bunny Garden yesterday.
Yesterday was Majang.
You guys said bunny...
You guys are gaslighting me.
You guys said bunny garden.
Then it was two days ago.
We are tired, too.
It was bunny garden because I missed yesterday.
Well, then there we go.
I was focused on the assets, okay?
made me leak through my ears so okay grandma time for bed
shut up thanks for the tournament always fun to see you gush
over things you love hope the new cat just well thank you I
hope that this was different enough from the last time that
I did the tour so that um you know you could see hopefully
here's some new things I mean things have updated in akiba
and the unfortunate thing is there's cars blocking the way
but also uh we don't have like you know a 2024 map yet but
next time i go um i will i will take some footage myself and
i will share it with you guys where is where are the ols
just giving the toward guy a tip i hope Oh, a tip!
I thought you meant you were telling me like a tip as in
like advice.
Thank you so much for that spooky super chat.
Hope to visit Akiba Sunday so I was taking notes.
Maybe I can go see the Made Mint, Made Cafe.
I hope one day I can collab with the Made Cafe.
That'd be crazy.
Maybe one day.
I gotta get bigger.
Maybe I got to get picker.
Where are we at?
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
I think 2022 is our best bet.
Because it has moved around a little bit.
The OL Cafe.
I'll find it.
Someday.
Here's a tip.
Don't quit your day job.
Heyo.
Here's an advice.
Take this dip stop.
Yeah, who would quit their day job to stream?
That's so silly.
That's actually like the worst idea ever.
That's like, who would risk it all?
Who would risk it for the biscuit?
Ugh.
This is so much fun, you guys.
I thought I would have to cancel because my head has been
hurting these past couple of days.
Probably because I've been just a little stressed out about
the cats.
And just some other stuff, too.
But, you know, I'm doing my best.
Going in October, this gave me some great ideas on where to
go.
Thanks, man.
Thanks, Bragg.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't wait to hear all about it.
you can be the Anna Miller's mascot because they're dead too
who's Anna Miller
I'm going to Japan in September thank you for the Rex yeah
of course of course of course but yes but I'm gonna rest
tomorrow and hope you guys liked this tour hopefully I'm
glad if it gave you some recommendations, some ideas of how
to get around Akihabara so when you go, you don't feel
entirely lost or overwhelmed.
And yeah, thank you for risking it.
Here's some money for the biscuits.
This tour was fine.
Thank you.
Yeah, we'll do a part two.
Isn't the Kandam Yodin Mu stairs down here too?
Yes, it is.
Right here.
This is actually the stick.
Oh, that's a wall.
This is the stairs to Kandam Yodin.
The stairs that they go to in Love Live.
That they run up and down.
Thanks for reminding me.
What do you feed for your new kiddie mint?
Oh, I don't really want to get into it because I've been a
little stressed about it.
Basically, my...
Butaro, he stopped eating.
him to the vet they were like he's really healthy but he's
lost two pounds and so i was really stressed about that
because he had he i kept having to give him some medicine
which would stress him out because he had like something
going on on his arm and so that was stressing out and then
stressing him out and then the new cat was stressing him out
and then he was getting skinny and so he just wasn't eating
a lot and so um uh i've had to start cooking him chicken
like actual He won't eat anything else.
My spoiled cat.
But, um...
Uh...
But, uh...
So, yeah, I was really stressed about that.
Because I was...
I would just, like, sit there trying to get him to eat
anything.
And I was just, like, sitting on the floor crying.
Trying to get my cat to eat.
So, sorry if my brain is scattered.
been and then i've been trying to um get my maid cafe ready
for when mataro visits so i've been trying to rearrange some
stuff and um yeah anyway sorry i didn't mean to bother you
guys with all that i try not to i try not to show it on
stream but if i'm scatterbrained because i'm stressed i'm
really sorry um but yeah i try to not to show it on stream
and try not to bother you guys with it so we can just have a
fun time right this tour was awesome I'm gonna be reviewing
this mod and mark down all the places I want to go to for my
own trip thank you meet up thank you Todd meet up what are
those stairs your name no no these are the stairs that lead
up to Kanda Miojin the stairs in love life the stairs that
they it's a different anime but look Kanda Miojin
Oh my gosh, Hanami in my stream!
Wow, nice!
Extra snack funds for the kitty and the main, thank you.
Yeah, this is where Nozomi works in Love Live.
There's also a lot of Gochi Usab.
What's the word the little things that you write your wishes
on if you go to if you go to these There used to be a lot of
love live and go to so Good tour hundred percent spoiled
kitty.
Yes, he is But yeah, I'm going to go sleep now actually no I
have some cleaning I need to do But thank you guys hold on
I hope you enjoyed the tour.
Don't mind that I'm huge.
It's a perspective thing.
It's perspective.
I'm not a giant or anything.
I'm not going to crush these people or anything.
I'm not a giant.
Ah, splatter.
Cheese!
I can't love Miojin!
Hold on.
I don't want to look like a nerd.
Cheese!
I can't love Miojin!
Thank you guys!
This is where we'll end the tour.
For today.
For now.
Until I have more places to recommend you.
Next time I go!
This is a nice spot to end it, right?
It's a beautiful sunny day.
The flowers are blooming.
My allergies are acting up.
Hi too.
I went to a Chica Idol Taiwan in Kanda, oh, oops, in Kanda
Miyajin, Culture Center back during my first trip here in
December.
Free Cheki is so good.
Yeah, a lot of groups have been doing the free Cheki thing
for the first time you see it.
For the first time you see them.
Hi Sim, mecham, mecham, tanosikata!
means thank you guys like i said we'll do we'll do a part
two bless you thank you and um hope you enjoyed it uh i
don't know why i like tried why i'm struggling to end this.
Maybe because I feel like I have so much more I could talk
about.
Next time.
Your passion lifts my spirits.
My spirits.
Okay, I really need to go sleep.
Otzumito, everyone.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.
See you, see you, see you, see you!
See you!
Not tomorrow.
Sunday!
Bye bye!
Oh, it's heavy!